chair of the house ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the 2019 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 in
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee meeting dealing with
revenue
please note there is no physical
location for members
of the public to observe and listen
contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaries during
this meeting through the electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
notice that this meeting complies with
health schools rsa
91-a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600
or email hcs like.state.nx.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff around the
meeting to assist us
christopher shea and brad greenland
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's stop at the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
and each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
okay representative bernstein you want
to take the roles
thank you representative major let's
begin the roll call with
representative abrami they're in my home
in stratham my wife is in the house
representative mary griffin
star six mary
i'm this is mary griffin i'm alone in my
home in windham
it's wonderful to have you mary thank
you representative owery
holman hudson my wife is in the house
representative ober
home and hudson the vice chair of
finances downstairs on a zoom meeting
with finance
representative doucette good morning
home alone in salem
representative bershteen is in his home
office in nottingham by himself
representative
representative elliott representative
jeninjian home alone and sale
i'm sorry i'm in salem alone in my
office but my wife and daughter are
somewhere in the house
representative nunes good morning i'm
home alone in pelham
representative tim baxter thank you
representative i'm home alone
representative spillsbury home alone in
charlestown my wife is elsewhere in the
house
representative tudor home alone in
northwood
representative almighty
on i'm home alone in lebanon on
representative ames can't find his
invite and needs to be contacted
i just forwarded it to the to him
a minute ago and i yeah and i emailed
him and told him
it will come back to uh representative
ames representative
southworth home alone in dover
representative malloy
i'm in greenland in my home office and
my wife is
in the house representative schomburg
i'm in my truck headed back to
wilmington
representative tucker home alone
in randolph representative gomarlo
paul malone and swansea representative
laughman
representative laughman representative
gordon
good morning i am here and i'm by myself
representative hacken phillips good
morning i
am here in concord in my office alone
representative murphy good morning i'm
here alone in my office in hanover
representative ames yes i'm here
alone and jeffrey representative major
i'm here in placer and my wife is in the
house
there are 22 of us here two of us are
not here
the two of them not here is dussett and
elliot
is that it no elliott and laughman you
said
is present oh okay
thank you
okay this morning we're here to
work on revenues and to
start getting the feel of
what our position will be and chris is
here to help us
he had emailed you the worksheets
the latest worksheets and on the latest
worksheets i hope you all haven't and
you
made a copy and you want to explain what
the difference between that
the latest worksheet is that you produce
chris
no i'm happy to do so um reps of major
so based on the conversation you had
with um dra last week they had suggested
a new range for the interest in
dividends
so on the dra high and low estimate
sheet
i increased the range in fiscal 21
to 135.5 and as a result
in column d and f those numbers adjusted
they also gave you a new number for the
communication services tax of 38.8 so i
included that
and then for the utility property tax of
42.3
and then i carried that number into the
actual worksheet
that has all the different revenue
sources in it and
before you go any further uh chris
referred to worksheet number three
the latest handout that we were emailed
go ahead okay this stop is going to rose
page 4 right
um so i'm looking at the excel document
it would be
um the sheet tab that's dra hi-lo
estimate
okay if you click that open if you're
looking at um
that's page free
so in that row 13 is the interest in
dividends
and column b is where you see the first
change to 135.5 and as a result of that
change
columns d and f um increased
and then in the communication services
they the dra provider
16 provided a new number of 38.8 based
on
january information so that
there was no um change in in the 2223
it's a flat
estimate throughout and the same with
the utah
utility property tax on line 22 gave you
a new number of 42.3
um and they make no estimate on a higher
low for the
that revenue source mainly because those
two revenue sources are fairly stable
the communication services tax they feel
is starting to um
plateau i mean for a while was
continually going down but
with some changes i think they
anticipate it should be
flattening out and the same with the
utility property that's a fairly
um stable revenue source
it's fairly consistent um
so i see a couple hands up represent
major i don't know
well representative
just a quick technical point uh could we
refer to this spreadsheet as february 2
because it doesn't say it's the third
one
yep it's february 2nd 2021
is the date that's in the spreadsheet
and that's
again because of when the conversations
were had with dra
i i can put it up on the screen i know
that when i share a screen or somebody
shares a screen sometimes it
creates challenges for members when
they're trying to look at stuff that
they have on their screen
so i guess i would take guidance from
the committee when you want me to share
something
otherwise i'll just try to guide you
verbally
i think um by putting it on the screen
very meaningful yeah it's good
okay i just know like if some people are
trying to do stuff on their
own it sometimes causes a problem so
i'll share it and
we'll go from there
so you should you should see the excel
sheet now
yes we do so that the tab is the dra
high low estimate tab
and then this is the the row that was
impacted
first the interest and dividends and the
135 is
the number that they gave you that was
new
the trifle small
um hold on
better or still needed to be larger
that's great
okay yes and then the next one was the
the communication services tax which
again
uh it was just a flat number they
changed it's a 38.8
um i think it was 38.2 last time
and then the utility property tax was
42.3
and that was a decrease from the
previous estimate was 43
i feel like it was 43.2 but i'd have to
look back at an old sheet
and then those changes carry forward
into the next tab
the gf etf worksheet
so if you go to column g you should see
the 135
the 143 6 and the 147.9 in the high
and then the same thing for
communications you'll see it's 38 all
the way through
and then in the utility property tax you
should see it's 42.3 all the way through
so that was the only changes to the
worksheet everything else stayed the
same
so i don't know what you want to do at
this point represent major or how you
want to
proceed
what i would like to be able to do is
get an agreement on those taxes that we
feel comfortable with
that the we'll take the agency's numbers
to me the first good candidate on that
would be
the insurance
tax
they've always been pretty right on
so go into the insurance
had his hand up that's all i was going
to say
oh representative romney
you're muted pat
that you're muted
make a motion that we accept the
insurance numbers as is
um she has a good history of
of knowing her stuff and doing pretty
good revenue estimates
the last presentation she made was as
detailed as you're going to get i mean
she broke it down into the
microscopic portions of of what makes up
this these revenues
and i i don't see how we can um
i don't know what she said makes sense
to me is what i'm getting at so
uh i just make the motion and we'll have
the discussion
uh but i think i i you know
i i don't think any of us could come oh
i know i can't come up with any numbers
better than
what she has done here so thank you
representative bromley made the motion
we accept
the numbers that the insurance company
insurance
agency has come up with uh anybody
second that
i'd be happy okay
then discussion
um yeah representative ames
i just want to be sure this the uh
are we are we doing two a high and a low
um or a single figure yes
yes uh whereas
where we feel it's necessary
uh high and low then
don't take this wrong this is where our
best estimate is at this point in time
of current law things may change
two weeks from now and we're going to
continually look at these things
and if the changes are such that we need
to
make a change in our estimates and we
will do that
but the information that we have at this
point in time
and from and that means
listening to the economists listening to
the experts
listening to the agencies
and what we know this will be our best
guesstimate at this point in time so for
this round we'll
do a high and a low on the other
agencies it doesn't
uh pertain to this particular
set of estimates um because they're all
the same
and i'm fine with them going forward
with the motion
can i chime in please yes
yeah again the spreadsheet's only set up
for
uh a single number uh
well i guess i guess chris
can i ask a question of course we get to
the ones where dra day array gave us the
high and so the lows
did this the spreadsheet is it is it's
it's not really set up for highs and
lows yet
before when we get so reps on broadway
as you can see i just added another row
yep it's magic you can easily add the
second row and make it high low
if that's the desire of the committee
but in the
can i just ask a clarifying question as
the committee's starting to discuss this
at the end of this process you're going
to have a single number correct
yes yes because i i'm not sure if
people on the committee have heard but
finance is already
looking to get the ways and means
estimates might be as they start to work
on the budget
right the vice chair of finance
called me or i called her because she
sent me an email
and we discussed this last night and our
goal
is on the 23rd is to hand them our
estimate at that point in time they're
very happy with that
and our estimates will be will contain
both highs and lows
on those that we feel there ought to be
a spread
and then a single number
on such as the insurance so
they're happy with that so our goal is
on the 23rd to be able to
provide that in between
we're going to be working them we're
also going to be sitting down with the
governor's budget director
i believe that's the 17th or the 18th
because by that by that time
well we know the governor's presenting
his budget i believe
on the 11th i said chris to the yes he's
going to be presenting
on the 11th i believe at noon time i'm
not sure
what the format is yet it's going to be
some sort of a remote but i'm not sure
what type of remote setting it's going
to be
the intention is that usually what
happens when the governor presents his
budget is our office will get hard
copies
of the budget as well as the budget
summary
so we anticipate we're going to get the
those documents
sometime around noon one o'clock on
thursday
11th and we will email and excuse me we
will mail
a hard copy of the um governor's budget
summary
to all the ways and means members so
that you can see the revenues in there
and then um from that point
we'll have something obviously go on our
website as well but i will also try to
extrapolate the governor's numbers into
a format so that you can see them so
um typically on this this worksheet
see where row nine is usually right
after the official plan we'll put in the
governor's estimates but we hadn't had
them yet so i didn't
have a row for that yet but once we get
them i can put them in here so you can
see how they sit
um compared to comparative to the plan
for 21 as well as the agency high low
estimates and then
how they would compare to the agency
estimates for 22 and 23.
um having not seen the governor's
estimates yet
what i don't know is um what
changes there are to revenues which
might impact
um the numbers so i that's something
where i may need to discuss with matt
may you who's the governor's budget
director to try to peel away
um changes in the revenues streams
you know there's a suggested
tax change that they're incorporating in
their estimate we'll need to peel that
out
um he is going to come matt is scheduled
to come before you on the 18th
right to discuss the the governor's um
revenue estimates and and
address any questions the committee
might have and i think between now and
then as you work on
estimates and and you hear the
governor's presentation you may have
a fair amount of questions the other
piece that's going to be different this
year about the budget
um is that house bill 2 needs to come
out at the same time as the budget there
was a piece put in the um
last house bill 4 which it was the
trailer bill that required that
so hopefully that will help with
identifying
for this committee identifying where
there might be tax changes being
suggested
if there are any i don't know but if
there are you could at least see that
language that's associated with that
um at this point i don't know what the
format will look like
again it's the governor's budget um it
hasn't been drafted
by the office of legislative services as
of yet
but they're supposed to provide language
at this time
on the 11th just as soon after the 11th
lpa should be providing us with that
what information they can relative to
the revenues on the governor's budget
we will have two hours with the
governor's budget director on the 18th
so we can determine how much of his
revenue estimates our current law and
what's not
current law which would be in house bill
2.
so we can differentiate between the two
and
we need to provide the best of the
finance committee is revenue estimates
for current law
and then anything other than current law
we have to address these one at a time
anything else on that quest i don't but
i i see reps on
me and reps over brahmi both have their
hands up i don't know if it's personal
thank you there's a lot to unpack at
this point but
on first a request on
are you going to to send to all of us
whatever you can
manage of what the governor's
revenue uh proposals and estimates
are uh are about by uh
by email or send us a link that you put
up on the website
because uh some of us live in the 037
zip code and won't get
mail for well these days maybe a week
and a half
um so yes that's the short answer to
your question
so we'll eat we will mail you a hard
copy of the governor's budget summary
which will have your the revenues in
there um but we
also will be putting stuff on our
website or links on our website to the
governor's budget in the summary and
that i will email you
and if i'm able to comfortably
identify his revenues from what might be
changes i'll
put together something in a spreadsheet
for you probably
add it to the worksheet and send that to
the members as well
if i'm having issues or i can't get it
done quickly i'll let you know that as
well
what i don't want to do is is compound
you know
for instance if if they show me a
business tax number
and i haven't been able to reach out to
matt to understand
how they got to their number because
they have language that is changing the
tax rates
i don't want to put it in there to show
that that's the number because there's
going to be an adjustment if we want to
stick with
um current law so for those members that
were on the committee two years ago
you'll recall we had a sheet
where the top half was current law and
then the bottom half was
the changes that were being proposed by
the governor and then by the house and
the senate
i'm anticipating creating that type of
sheet for you again
because when i talk to governor's budget
director he understands
we're going to be talking to him to
identify
what those revenues are under current
law and those that
rely upon house bill 2. yep mr chairman
yes the second point was
on if if we can somehow make
time that we consider on
the proposals of his that we don't have
as bills already
and provide information on them to the
finance committee because
in the past the finance committee has
sometimes gone ahead
with tax changes that
they didn't really understand and that
didn't work
this is why i'm talking about my own
party here
so this is why we're having that meeting
on the 18th to identify this
and then we can attack each and every
one of these changes
on house bill 2 that's required for
their revenues
thank you yeah representative brown
niece
you have your hands up yep i do uh so uh
i think for the for the committee we've
really got to understand when we're
going to put this
first stake in the ground officially uh
in terms of a resolution to the house
floor
to me that becomes the official
statement of this committee as to
what we think the revenues are and i
understand that as the months go on
we're going to be updating that and
probably have additional resolutions
but uh i i would imagine that finance is
going to take that resolute their first
resolution is the number they have to
work with is that is that a safe to say
and uh when do you think that will be
that we have to do that
you're scheduled to meet the 23rd
representative on the 23rd
i told lynn it was then over
that we would be meeting to put together
our draft numbers and
she will run with those draft numbers
because to get a resolution
we need to be able to get it to a
session
and i'm going to have to talk to the
speaker to see
we know we're going to have a session on
the 24th and 25th
to see if we can uh it would be too late
to do a resolution on either the 24th to
25th
even if it is they're going to run with
our draft numbers
those draft numbers going to be a range
i think traditionally it's not been
arranged correct
what we will do is for
the finance committee split the
difference
but we'll still have our range
and for for a uh house resolution
we did that last last time that was
susan we had a range
but i think uh chair mr chair i think
that was
that wasn't the last time was in the
summer
last time was after the virus hit
i don't think i don't think the
resolution the official resolution that
we did during the budget cycle which was
well before covert
those ranges we did the range maybe i'm
mistaken but i if i
we can double check that but my
recollection is that
for the budget we gave them a number for
each of these
revenue streams we will do what makes
sense
at that at the point in time
so so representative abrami is correct
in that
house resolutions 16 was done over the
summer was a range
the ways and means committee wanted a
range because of all the
dynamic issues that you were dealing
with at that time there was just a lot
of unknowns
and it was the best information was
arranged at that time
prior to that for the budget it was a
single number
for each of the revenue categories which
makes
probably better sense because you don't
want the finance committee potentially
spending more money than
there's finances to but revenues to take
care of
yeah and we can make that decision
what that will be on the 23rd
but we'll still operate with the range
but we'll give the finance a number
they'll also know what our range is too
uh representative romney
yep no i'm i'm sad
oh okay you have your hand up oh i
forgot to put it down thank you
all right any further questions from
anybody else
thank you on just to go back to
insurance
i believe that this one we
only get um analyzed real numbers
in april so
what she's given us i think has to be
the best we're going to get
they are very good at this right
and when we look at this again in may
and june right before the committee
conference convenes
uh
make our final adjustments
any further questions on the insurance
all right um then this is what we'll
without any objection this is what we're
going to
go with at this point in time
represent bursting has his hand up reps
of major
thank you representative bernstein thank
you
uh representative abrami made a motion
is this just an acclimation thing or are
we actually going to vote on it or does
anyone have any objections to the motion
enough there's emotion dangling now
right are there any objections to this
motion
without any objection we don't have to
vote
make life easier
okay the next candidate that we
feel pretty confident on
every member of this committee has heard
the his history of the of each of these
revenue streams
has been introduced to the agency heads
again
and got the latest information from the
agency
what they anticipate the numbers will be
for
21 22 and 23.
from what you've heard is there another
candidate that
we can easily get done now
how about column p
or actually yeah column p
um which p are we talking about
mr chairman statewide qualified
okay there is an hour
mr chairman do you want us to make a
motion each time or shall we just
discuss
it first why don't we discuss it
on column p which is statewide property
tax
that's set by statute at this point in
time statute
hasn't been changed um
the statute calls for 363.1 million
dollars
sometimes it varies those 1.2 or
whatever anybody have any comments
no i i i agree that uh we should
simply put down 363.1 as the statutory
number
um its current law okay
then one is the representative romney i
can carbohydrate as well does anybody
not compare with that
then
the statewide property tax is defined in
column
p at 363.1
will go with that at this point in time
since the statutes have not been changed
another candidate you may want to
consider is
column n
you've heard the
representative from the attorney
general's office and then talk to us
so i'm going to let the committee
make a decision on this
representative elmi first
on i think we should take
their numbers the default of anything
else but i do wonder if either of our
lawyers has
any comment on the presentation
that was made
um anybody have any comments on the
presentation that's been made
well as a former lawyer i don't
very good
anybody else want to comment very
hacking
i i don't have anything to add sorry
[Music]
okay um then any objections
to going with the numbers that attorney
general
general's office came up with for the
tobacco settlement
i believe these numbers are are
from the national consortium that is
spending all of their time working on
what the number
is so
well just a question is is there
i can't remember is there a possibility
that they'll come back to us with new
information
and a different number you know there
always is
because over the years uh it does change
sometimes and it depends upon
you know there's a possibility it may
even go up a bit
but i don't know how far behind they are
because
it seems like smoking has gone up a bit
since
these are good numbers right now we
don't have anything else so i think
right smart just put it in
so can we uh anybody have any objections
christie has been putting his hand up
not virtually
chris i can't put my hand up virtually
because i'm a co-host
so i have to raise it in the screen
let's apologize
i just wanted to um responded uh
representative ames question when uh mr
saison came and spoke with you he
indicated that the soonest they might
have any new information might be in
april
when settlement money comes in they may
have
at that point they may have some other
information that may impact going into
22-23 but he wasn't um
overly optimistic about that um
and then when you're done when you when
you've agreed on what you want to do
with tobacco settlement i just wanted to
bring up one issue
related to it that's it's not directly
tied to the revenues
indirectly okay uh
just as soon as we're finished what
might make a change
is the non the amount of money that's
been put together
by the non-participating manufacturers
and that will be decided on the
month you receive in april
ahead press so
in in the education trust fund statute
it um basically is a flat figure for the
tobacco settlement it says that 40
million dollars of the tobacco
settlement will be deposited there
i was talking with the comptroller um
yesterday or the
day before um and and she's wondering if
that maybe that language should be
amended to an up to 40 million amount if
we start to collect
less than 40 million from the tobacco
settlement
and i believe the concern is um will
some people interpret that that there
needs to be
40 million dollars put into the trust
fund even if the settlement money
doesn't bring in 40 million
so it's just an issue um i've asked her
to check
with the governor's um office to see if
they've had any concerns with that and
if they've included anything or
plan on including anything in their
budget proposal
but if not it may be something that you
know you guys might want to consider
and then we talk to finance and see if
they can put something in maybe house
bill 2.
very good point because particularly
where the
estimates are going down in the out
years we've been so far we've collected
40 million plus
every year even though the estimate for
last year was 39 and change
uh we still got 42 million we don't know
and and and based
on the conversation um the attorney
wasn't real optimistic we were going to
be going back up in the 40 million
dollar range
one good question to ask again from
the attorney general next time you see
him how much of that
42 and a half million dollars we
received
in 2020
was due to the non-participating
manufacturers
but that is that percentage been going
up each year
okay
all right i might even have my hand up
here
thank you so just to remind the
committee
uh that these numbers are based on the
amount of smoking that happens across
the country not just new hampshire
uh we may have had a little bit of
oblique because of the virus in terms of
an increase
just like this it seems to be an
increase in drinking and other things
but there's no question that it's
steadily been going down
at least in my tenure here in the house
uh that
uh and the other data variable is is
vaping
that some people have taken up vaping
instead of smoking
uh but vaping is not covered under this
settlement agreement
only the smoking part so it makes sense
that the numbers are going down
uh the way they are so let's find a
comment those are good points
okay are we all set for state uh for
tobacco settlement funds
mr chairman
could representative ask also the
attorney general's office
on whether they can
tell us if uh our
cigarettes sold goes go up while
on the general number is going down
on i i believe we don't get fully
compensated for us
going going up but i'm not sure
how the formula works on that because we
are getting
considerably more at least i it may not
even be for the year that they're
covering at this point
on because massachusetts banned menthol
it isn't are people smoking it it's
massachusetts people smoking it
but that is the increase
but that may even just figure into the
formula next year and if it does
then we could be seeing an increase
in 22.
so ribs and volume your question is just
to see if new hampshire benefits by the
increased
tobacco sales um is there some waiting
that occurs as a result of that
so i'll ask them the question
i'd like to weigh in on that i my
recollection and i could be wrong
is that when this when this
settlement was reached that we were
locked in
to a percentage of the total
based on smoking at that point in time
i don't know if that's suggested so
that's my recollection but we should get
you know confirmation of that uh chris
yep so um but i i don't think it varies
based on
we as a state our goal ours goes up or
down
i know definitely that um
that it's based on the overall is based
on overall
united states smoking whether it's gone
up or down uh
in terms of the amount of the settlement
but
but the question on the table is how is
that allocated does that change
the allocation of the total amount
change
or not yep
i'll reach out to him and see what he
can provide
would be nice to know too is
how is the non-participating
manufacturers
affecting this from year to year
is it do they contribute more to the pot
or is it about the same ratio
okay another candidate
representative major mr chairman this is
representative nunez i do have a
question
yes representative i i just want
clarification and maybe for some other
of the other new members that are on the
line as well uh we start out talking
about the
tobacco settlement column on line in and
then i think we flipped over and started
talking about the
the the general tobacco tax
in column c um can we make clarification
that
we're looking at the possibility of less
than 40
in column in and uh
credit to um to mr shea in uh
in talking about the possible need for
an amendment
uh to make it up to 40 so that uh
revenue wouldn't be
tied up sort of out of statute or or
be needing to be funded from somewhere
else if 40 has to go into that account
am i correct in
understanding that chris
yep so that i believe that's the concern
that
the comptrollers has and i'm in the
middle of um
email exchanges with her right now so i
had sent some information back to her
and requested some clarification
but i just wanted to make the committee
aware that this may be something that's
going to be recommended i asked her to
put something in writing if it truly is
so that i could share it with the
committee so that you you could at least
see the rationale behind it but i think
the concern is that
there might be an interpretation that um
you know
you have to provide 40 million dollars
to the education trust fund and if the
settlement is less than that how does
that occur
so i think just to make sure it's very
clear to those that have to
um apply the law
in terms of the accounting so that
there's no question that they're they're
they're doing anything
um irregular or not
thank you mr shea that's that's what i
understood i know that we start we
started talking about two columns at the
same time and it was just a little
confusing to me
it was i was thinking that maybe there's
something that's tied those two columns
together
and i wanted to get that clarified if i
might i think
the the entire conversation was focused
on the tobacco settlement
they heard the mention of um to other
tobacco
is the menthol sales in new hampshire
somehow factor in if we are
having more sales in new hampshire
factor into how it's apportioned out
in terms of the settlement so that was a
question that i've been asked to check
in with the
doj attorney about in which that revenue
stream
come in under column c correct excuse me
that that that revenue for the menthol
for the menthol cigarettes would come in
under column c
yes yes so when you're collecting your
tobacco tax for the state which you
which you're not discussing at the
moment um that would be under column c
it was just a anecdotal comment about
um tobacco sales generally in new
hampshire
and if we're selling more as a result of
our surrounding states making changes
we somehow benefit in the tobacco
settlement as a result of that
thank you very much i'm all cleared up
now right we haven't
started discussing ceo
okay um has their hand up for episode
major
okay well represented just
just for the new people
don't hesitate to ask questions there's
no stupid question or a silly question
you don't get something fine ask the
question
thank you just a comment to chris
the language that you're talking about
for the tobacco settlement would be
something that would go
into into house bill 2
by the finance committee correct i i
think so how do we do it
i i think it the easy in my mind in
looking at what's out there for bills
and stuff i think that would be the
easiest place to marry it so that it
travels with the budget
um i bring i mention it to you and
you as the committee um just so you're
aware
um and and and if there needs to be
conversations between
leadership of the ways and means
committee and house
finance committee um that that could be
had
but again i just didn't want to um have
something be done in house bill 2
that is traditionally something that
this committee would look at
i just wanted you to be aware that
that's a conversation that's occurring
um and i'll i'll let you know in the
next couple of meetings what i get back
from
the comptroller and um if it is still
something that really needs to occur or
if they've
they've felt comfortable leaving it
alone or not
but again i just wanted to make mention
of it now in case you hear or see it
down
down the road um just a follow-up
question
because i have more information
representative major
yes who is that representative
um chris i just wondered if you could
give us the statutory reference for this
40 million dollar
division um
one moment 1077
e i think it's around
it's in the early sections
it it's actually in the education
statutes
so i'm just grabbing it now
we could hear it later
okay so
[Music]
stop
just
it's a statement of an amount of
annually
i think the comptroller is just
concerned if you're collecting less than
that
i understand i understand it's a good
point and it may
need to be corrected 198.39
yep all right thanks a lot
okay okay we have identified three
columns so far
the insurance tax
tobacco settlement and the statewide
property tax
as something that we have confidence in
these numbers
that's another one
representative court confined
court uh fine fees
what's in the model i was going to
suggest communication
tax in the other
column column l why don't we take
communication tax first
which is column g
person major if at any point it's
helpful too
to bring up the documents from um past
meetings
just let me know that and i can pull up
an agency's document and that way you
can
view that on the screen together could
you pull up this one
okay
if hey pat
can you just take over for a minute i'll
be back in a few minutes
yes i can
age 39 thank you you're welcome
so
so that gives you um the overview and
and when it's
paid
right here's the 10-year trend for the
tax
right and we'll hold it right there i
mean dying i call it a dying tax
because basically because of the
landlines uh people are giving up their
landlines that which is a
biggest source of the revenue
businesses keep their landlines for for
certain you know for a reason
uh but individuals are abandoning the
landlines because they have their cell
phones
um
just a question i don't remember the
answer to this but
we all know that there's been a lot of
zoom activity
and that's two-way i believe so
do we have any information on how if at
all
that activity may or will
impact on this well the one thing we did
we did get was that
yes the zoom zoom is taxed and other
other platforms like that are taxed uh i
don't recall seeing any breakout
chris can you recall that so when when
the commissioner
of dra lindsey stepp spoke to you he
indicated that they're in discussions
right now
as it relates to those types of
platforms some of
the entities that should be paying or
potentially be paying
so it's an unresolved i guess at the
moment
so that so it wasn't included i don't
believe it was included in any of their
estimates
per se um they did talk about the this
flattening out a little bit
and um this past session
there was language that um clarified um
the voip and and um
i guess is it like flip phones uh track
phones
like they are communication service
taxes applicable to those
and there was some revenue estimates
associated with that i think it was two
and a half million for this uh
this fiscal year 21 and they assumed
that was going to help
balance out some of the losses and
that's why i was going to plateau to
some extent
yeah because when i when i looked at the
numbers i said geez
that's a good update on on what what
they said
because i i when i just looked at them
this morning i went wow
it looks like it flattened and it's
bucking the trend so they must have
factored in something for that
and it sounds like what you just said is
is what they've
assumed in their estimates
would it be reasonable could we ask for
an update uh
from dra i'm sorry yeah about the zoom
uh another related but yeah i think we
do that maybe we maybe put this one on
hold
we're not going to do all the revenues
today
you know we're probably going to do the
big ones later you know business taxes
meals and rooms you know those are the
ones that we're still waiting for more
information on
um we're basically trying to trying to
get
some of the smaller ones up but this is
a dra
maybe we can hold on this one today is
that okay with everybody
i've had my hand up for a while yep i i
can't think
yeah that's okay susan sorry i'll i'll
try to remember that and just try to
break in
uh the the they are still trying to
figure out what you
tax consume right and zoom has been
extremely
important and is going to continue to be
important when it wasn't before so we
really don't know yet whether we're
going
whether we're going to be able to i mean
all we do is collect
license fees as far as i can tell
and are we allowed to tax those or not
the legislation probably needs to be
clarified once they've gotten further
representative this is something next
year or the year after maybe we're going
to
yeah we we need to get the dra
in again on this okay
what i might suggest um you know where
dra has a lot of these
um taxes that probably are going to have
questions related to them
then that you have your discussions
today and
and um tuesday and that maybe i could
invite
dra to come back on that thursday to
speak after the
governor's budget person and
to address any questions you might have
as it relates to some of these taxes and
and
that may it's only a week but maybe
there will be something new that they
can also share
okay okay that'd be fine and then as you
ask questions i'll keep track of them
and i'll provide them to draw
for any of those taxes you might have uh
needing
more information or just clarification
on something
yeah because with this curve to say
that the future is going to be flat
there's got to be some reason
and we don't have that right now
mr chairman we do have that they've
managed to make the void
and flip fun ratio work
so that's what flattened the curve
my curve is something that
has happened
and you're pretty sure that it's going
to remain flat
in the future i'm not sure
all right so we need to definitely
question the communication service tax
well the representative is a good one
there
the next one you mentioned too
jenna you need to move on
sorry i tried to use the space bar um i
mentioned the other
column which is l or or n if you're
looking at the
spreadsheet
[Music]
that one has a lot of
revenue sources but most of revenue
sources are extremely small
compared to about about a half a dozen
other
better than 200 revenue sources
and unfortunately when
the time and the interest revenue was
high
and it dropped it was offset by
something else
and
you have anything to say on on others uh
chris just to um to piggyback your
comment about interest revenue
going forward they're not projecting any
um
revenue from interest right
we had to benefit this last biennium
that they were um
we were pretty cash heavy and they were
able to invest money and we're earning
interest on that
with the way everything's been going um
they have made some adjustments so
they're not making any predictions on
any interest
that would be that would be basic if we
do get any interest going forward
that would be one of those surprise
revenues that maybe offsets one that
doesn't come in as strong as they had
anticipated
right but i just wanted to clarify that
because last time last budget
there was a lot of discussion about um
interest revenue and how much was going
to be generated
going forward in the 22 and 23 they're
they're not
estimating any interest revenue um i
have a question
yes and who is that representative james
uh representations would help if you
raise your hand
oh i thought you couldn't see my hand
so this is a question for chris and
i believe at times in the past
the other column has has uh
been added to by settlement money
in uh individual cases now i may be
misremembering that mostly
many times settlement money is
segregated into
some special uh designated fund or
you know a specialized fund but um
sometimes
not and uh so maybe you could speak to
that and the
follow-up question is whether
we know or don't know if there is any um
sort of active court cases that might
trigger
settlement funds of significance
so so the answer is yes um
typically when you have some of the
smaller settlements that aren't
designated for a
a particular purpose they'll end up in
the other category as unrestricted
revenue you do have occasionally
um some of the settlements that are
entered into their they have a purpose
or judgments settlements or judgments
and they have a purpose
either because of that particular
settlement or judgment or because the
legislature has assigned a purpose to it
i think the mtp mtbe money is probably
um the most notable where there was the
two
almost 300 million dollars that came to
the state that was put into a dedicated
fund
and is is used to help with um clean
water and drinking water issues
um and there's a and that oversees that
so so it depends on what the legislature
if they're aware of money coming into
the state and if they do something that
directs it or if the courts have already
directed a use it may be restricted
are we am i aware of any large
settlement dollars coming down the pike
i am not
um you may recall a few months back that
securities um you're at a settlement of
two million dollars
so that sits in there um basically sits
in their bank account until the end of
this year
and it would be deposited into the
general fund at that point
um based on um whatever
expenses they have
the other thing to know about um
judgments and settlements that come into
the state
if it's in excess of a million dollars
ten percent of that goes to the rainy
day fund
and then the rest can go to the general
fund or whatever other purpose it might
have
um so there was a way that the
legislature thought it to kind of
put a little bit of money towards the
rating a fund
but it's it's hard to guess or estimate
when a a court settlement will be
completed
typically we learn about it the same as
everybody else and when there's a press
release
and and um the state's being told that
they they have money to use
another dedicated was the volkswagen
settlement you know that
that money is very specifically used for
um area shoes on vehicles and so there's
limits on how that money can be spent so
it's not it didn't
it never touched the general fund it's
managed out of the governor's office
can you put up this sheet on others
which shows the uh like the four or five
biggest ones
there we go that's the page you're
looking for yeah
so that this row here the miscellaneous
other revenue that would be
um all the other little funds
that they talked about and then here are
some of your larger the
indirect costs are funds that
um basically on federal dollars
and it's to cover um like
those things in in your agency that are
are centralized
so that you know the accounting staff
the human resources staff
that maybe the commissioner so those
indirect costs help cover that but it
comes in as revenue
to the state the same with the
post-retirement benefits
that's federal usually federal dollars
grants that come in to cover
retirement costs associated with
individuals that are working on federal
programs
abandoned property you heard a lot about
um the treasurer
deals with that and um in june basically
they transfer
an amount to the general fund and
they've made estimates
uh but the exact dollar won't be known
because they're in the process of
liquidating um
[Music]
bonds and stocks that they might have at
this time
and then as i mentioned the interest in
surplus funds
you can see there was a couple of years
in 1819
and then 20 where we had um a
good uptick in in the in the dollars
that we got in interest
and then in 21 it goes right down to
zero let's go back to 16 it was less
than a thousand dollars and prior to
that
it would have been in the few hundred
dollar range so it typically wasn't
included
um in 19 when the budget was being
prepared
uh there was a strong feeling that you
know we're getting some significant
dollars you should probably put that as
part of your
other estimate but things have changed
going forward so they've removed that
and then here with the office of
professional licensure and certification
that used to be uh money that went to
the general fund when they consulted all
those
uh boards um back in
i think it was 2015 as the language was
in that bit
in the house bill 2. um
then a couple years later the fund was
restricted
and it no longer went directly to the
general fund though there is
language um
there is language that says at the end
of the fiscal year
they deposit whatever's left in the fund
into the general fund
but up until that point the um
that the money is used to pay for the
boards and the and the
operations of the oplc
so those are those are some of your
bigger accounts
um
and then on this page page seven
these top 12 15
these are the ones that um the
comptroller discussed that
they they keep an eye on those because
those are typically some of your larger
historically have been some of your
larger
other revenues so that kind of gives
them a sense of how things would be
going
um but as
pointed out during the presentation
there are some that seem to be changing
like the aircraft fee has gone down
significantly
that was it was the result of statutory
change that occurred
um it actually restricted the some of
the money that used to come to the
general fund labor
is an interesting um it shows 980 but
basically they're a transfer at the end
of the year as well
so years ago uh
probably four budgets ago maybe
department of labor was all generally
funded any fees fines they collected
went to the general fund and then there
was a change to dedicate all their
revenues that they collected through
fines and fees and those were used to
pay for the agency with again at the end
of the fiscal year
um any bounce in in the administrative
fund would lapse to the general fund
so i don't know what else i can share
with you
or if there's any specific questions the
only
question i would have is there any of
those that
would be tied to the pandemic
or or those or any of the ones that
are trivial right now that could really
boil up because of the pandemic
otherwise
go on as usual
i i don't know and and i don't know if
um
the controller necessarily knows i can
check with her though
okay it may require her or her staff to
reach out to the agencies that are
excuse me that are providing the
revenues
again because it comes from a multitude
of the agencies i just don't know what
the impact is
um we probably wouldn't find out what
the impact was
probably until march and april
possibly not i mean and some of these
because they're their
fees it may also have to do with a cycle
of when they collect the fees
and and i i'm unfortunately i don't have
all that information you know is it a
once a year type of thing is it every
two years
is it twice a year i just don't know on
some of these
is it throughout the year but um
so that's all i have on the other and
represent major i see you've got a
number of hands up so i'll be quiet
okay thank you mr chairman i'd just like
to point out since we're on this page
on the initial plate and vanity
fund and vanity plate which is four down
on crashed for the pandemic they
it certainly will be coming back up
and restaurant fees down about six below
it
crashed because of the pandemic
but there are on
that's uh health and human service fees
from the restaurants but there are other
things that
that may have gone in the other
direction because we know that that
certain economic activity is
has been booming in the pandemic and
[Music]
and you can't look at the history of
this fund because they
keep on putting things into it and
taking them out again
over in finance and so
current law just reflects what they've
been doing recently
i don't see how we can second guess
their estimates on this even though i'm
not i don't think their estimates
are or can be very good unless they're
going to spend all of their time
going after all of the agencies
so i've tried occasionally to talk to
them
you said the initial plates crashed i
don't i don't see
that because the uh the actual for 2020
was
5147 and what's projected is 51.50 for
21.
so you're looking at the uh through
december numbers
is why it went down right but
um they're still projecting 51.50
that's still a problem of of when
the money comes in oops we just lost
but on and this is the problem they
um they have not had anything in sale of
real property for some years now because
they kept
putting in selling laconia and it didn't
sell
so that's just going to show up when it
shows up
i know it's been it's really been
decades
time to sell that uh representative
browning
yeah it just goes but i had my hand up
for a while so this goes back to the
conversation about
outstanding um settlements the only one
i can think of is the pfas
is out there i think 3m is being sued
and i think we're on we're we're
involved in that as a state
and that those things take four or five
years so
i i don't think um i don't think
it's going to come in in this period of
time that we're talking about here
but it's the foam you know the fire
retardant foam that was used and
manufactured by 3m i think i think it
was 3m
uh that's that's the big one that i my
memory tells me is out
still out there unsettled chris you have
something
i just wanted to suggest too that i
believe
you were all provided the kafir a hard
copy of it
or you can look at electronically but in
there there is
um um legal actions that are
taking place and some of these will be
mentioned
that you know you've mentioned or
represent others and
it might give you it doesn't usually say
you know on such a date we're going to
have a settlement but it might give you
an indication of
maybe how far along they are in a
process
and what they they're asked to
anticipate what the the
value of that might be either positive
or negative so if there's a suit against
the state
you know what's the potential liability
and if there's a suit for the state
what's the
potential gain you know often they can't
say that
for a number of different reasons but at
least you can see what types of um
court cases might be out there that
could have an impact on revenue
in the upcoming years but you can't ever
say for certainty when when
the dollars would actually hit the door
thank you mr chair um
i was actually when i suggested other i
was thinking railroad timber and
excavation which are three pages in
the dra packet so where do those come in
i can't seem to find it anywhere
uh you you won't because uh those
are um i think
i think those are all dedicated to a
purpose
i think that they use the funds uh the
timber funds are go back to the
communities
on the railroad fund there is direction
of where that goes in the statute
there may be small pieces that come and
some of it funds the activity within the
department but then
it gets split up into different ways i'd
have to look at the statutes exactly but
it's not included
in the dra's bigger revenue numbers if
anything
you might find it in the other revenue
and i'd have to do a search for that
i just wonder why timber
right railroad tax goes back to some
certain purposes as it relates to some
of the lines
around the state but i think a piece of
that might go into a different fund as
well and i would just have to confirm
that
thank you representative ah thank you
i'd like to go back um to what the
chairman said at the very beginning
um a lot of these are smaller revenues
and they are going to go
up and down and i think that may balance
out
but i don't think it will be way off so
when we look at the total
i think it's you know really the best
estimate they have right now
and i don't know if emotions in order
but i would support accepting their
total estimate
realizing that a lot of the smaller ones
are going to go up and down
do we have a second on that
i'll second it okay uh
anybody not agree with that
i don't see any hands raised
so we are through others for right now
okay another candidate
for the court finds normal court
just trying to pick off the little ones
here yep
put lines first column i
on page five
and that's been pretty consistent
and that's a whole bunch of little
things
a variety of courts
anything to add to that chris
nope i i think that donna did a pretty
good job with you the other day
um you know
she she continually analyzes the revenue
that they're collecting within the
courts
and tries to make her best guesses you
know going forward and
brings in a lot of um information to do
that for you
and that's why she provides the detail
that she does i can pull up her
presentation if that's helpful for the
committee
why don't you
[Music]
um
so this is uh page 12 of their
presentation is the historical so it
gives you
16 through 20.
and how they're doing they were doing
with their different revenue sources
and then on page 13
is 20 21 22 and 23
and when you're looking at um judicial
branch
you're considering for the courts and
fines
this line right here that
that that's the line that you're
estimating at this moment
so it's rolls everything up above that
rolls into that number
i i think we can do that the penalty
assessment is actually in other
is one of the other revenues it goes
into the other fund
sometimes you have to keep big picture
involved here this is such a small
revenue stream
that even if we're off by ten percent
it's not significant
if this was a business tax and we're off
by 10 that's another story
yeah i think we should accept this yep
patton
feel we should peterson the court
numbers
anybody not agree
then we will do that about the beer tax
it never changes the beer tax you're
right
okay that's amazing
for the newbies you know how much tax we
collect
on a gallon of beer
it's been the same for years and years
and years
anybody venture to guess
isn't it 30 cents 30 cents a gallon
mr chairman that's what i was going to
say it was about 30 cents a gallon
decades ago it's still 30 cents a gallon
and i'd like to point out people have
tried to get us to put it up
it would produce very little money and
we would be
above the states around us
right absolutely
so this would be a good candidate
to take the agency's numbers but don't
let me
make that decision the amazing thing is
that it's
a matter of recession not recession
highs lows
the world blowing up it seems to be the
same amount
year after it did it did grow
from 10 million i think uh or maybe it
was 12 million one
one million months uh when we were
first looking at this thing
i think that's the craft beer that's
come in
i think we should accept it but what
we're saying is we can
we can always rely on our beer drinkers
okay representative tucker says uh we
should accept
these numbers who agrees
who doesn't agree fine
here column k is okay
another candidate medicaid recoveries
it's practically nothing on
we know why it's going down
okay medicaid recovery is on page six is
called
cue
a good presentation on that from
hhs
did you just want to put the sheet up
first
um i can
oh
so that's what they gave us was the the
line graphs
and then the pie charts
and just as a reminder you know that
there were some higher collections back
in the earlier years
um with the um recovery income
and that's because there was a backlog
that was part of the issue there that
at a backlog that was ongoing and they
had hired some um
firms to help them address that
as meredith telus had also indicated
with the managed care contracts they've
negotiated that
function as part of that service so that
they're now taking that responsibility
on
and and the effort really is to um
try to stop a service from being paid
for before you actually
pay for something that wasn't um allowed
for
so that's what they're trying to do
going forward is to say not that it's
not covered this is what is covered
um
any questions on the medicaid recoveries
so are we all set medicaid recovery is
anybody not
all set
it looks great
okay but uh norm how about utility
property text now tax
utility property tax next after week
on medicaid recoveries we're all set on
that i didn't see anybody
not so okay
and the utility property tax is the next
candidate
can i just say something about that norm
yes
again that's that's taxes but the state
not by municipalities make sure there's
no
confusion on utilities
that would be the long lines and the
utility plant plants that around the
state
and we don't have much change in that
there aren't
other than upgrades in a plant or if a
major plant goes offline
basically this is the this is the
the tax that is fairly consistent year
after year
again unless we built another seabrook
or built another plant
you know we wouldn't see uh any major
change in this
right and this tax is a
my statute is a rate of six dollars and
sixty cents a thousand
is that right chris yes
and it stays that way and it's assessed
by the dra
and as pat says we don't see big change
on this unless a retiree
a power facility
but usually there's a one that comes
online
to offset that can accept what's here
thank you this this tax
is a uh calculated as an income
and expense tax so when the cost
of energy goes up the value of the
plants goes up on the market basis
and they end up on paying more
when on the other
thing about it is our energy policy
and the the um citizens energy policy
it's become increasingly difficult to
put in a new pipeline
that would be added to this on and
it's um it also includes
solar installations
and um on industrial solar and
installations and uh windmill
installations as i recall and um
those are probably not going to be
uh stimulated for a while
under under our current administration
and um so
that keeps it from going up any further
and it also may mean
that old oil plants
and and on the
the gas pipelines will do a little
better
in terms of their their revenue it's
it's kind of difficult for us to tell
but it does
it does go up and down
in cycles as you had more when they were
adding a lot more pipelines
it did go up
hydro plants are also part of this
and the value of these plants do vary
with the value of the cost of energy
all right missy rex and ames
yeah um question is
for chris do you know if there's a
list of utilities by location that are
paying this tax i don't but i can
ask dra yeah
i think i i i'd like to get that
and just as a general observation that
this uh
tax originated along with the statewide
education property tax which was at six
dollars and sixty cents an hour when it
was initiated
and the statewide education property tax
which is on
property across the state does not apply
to the property of the utility property
tax applies to
has a different tax base than the local
property tax
rate that's applied to property by
municipalities
so that would be helpful crazy good yep
uh thank you just a question um does
this tax
include dams like the one on the
connecticut river
uh in dms elsewhere yes it does
and how is how is it since the dam or
the river
or the property line for vermont and new
hampshire is on the vermont side
so is there any shared tax or is it all
new hampshire on these rivers the
connecticut specifically
i know the answer to that norm
yeah i was actually pulled into the uh
science and tech pulled me into a bill
last year that had to do with this
and basically it split right down the
middle
whatever the equipment is if it's on the
if the generators
you know the dam is is divided equally
because it theoretically goes right down
the middle
of the river uh of connecticut river but
if the
generating port is in in new hampshire
my understanding is that
we get the you know the generators
actually where the generators are
uh we get we get credit for it if it's
on the vermont side
they get credit for it it's my
understanding thank you
representative abrami the river belongs
to new hampshire
at the vermont on shoreline
as it was about 200 years ago or
something
oh that's news to me i i again there's a
whole bunch human beings
there's like at least uh eight or nine
dams along
going up from uh up and down the uh
our border uh and i
that was my recollection of the
conversation there's a bill right now
about this as well
that i've i've co-sponsored they asked
me to co-sponsor it
um but you know we'll learn more about
that or we can find out
if what i'm saying is correct but my
understanding is that there's
some kind of a because because there was
an assessor who was
challenging the methodology for the
assessment and
uh and how it gets split between the two
states chris would you check with the
dra
yeah i wrote the question down okay
representative southwest um
hi just to add to the conversation i do
believe also
that all of the bridges are new
hampshire's responsibility
because of what was said earlier and so
i think the bridges across the
connecticut
are generally on new hampshire's list
yes we pay for 80 percent of the bridges
uh cost and the and vermont pays for 20.
there are some exceptions though
represent yearly
yes thank you uh regarding the
connecticut river remember the issue we
had with the interstate compact
uh from the 1930 whatever flood
and all that some of
the distribution
and the formula for that comes from that
um interstate compact
which is why uh vermont uh gets some of
the money or some of the revenue from
the
from the taxes and also for yes vermont
got to pay for the
uh footing for the bridge over the
connecticut
um over just beyond keene there whatever
the name of the town that is
uh the new bridge they put in and we get
to
maintain the entire bridge right up to
the rotary and back
but i think we could accept these
figures now
okay representative tucker says
to accept the figures that
do anybody not agree with her
i see three hands still raised
representative murphy you have your
hands raised
all right you haven't taken it down okay
so i don't see any hands going up
so we'll take the figures from utility
property tax
we have another candidate
if you're ready to do d for liquor
transfer
which one d
stickers in dog
yes the liquor transfer
seemed fairly okay
you want to bring up the liquor sheet
yep
so
liquor sliced and diced their data
they should have provided a good set of
data
so what so what they're trying to show
on like this earlier slides
is they're bringing in 147
million dollars approximately not the
beer test but that's all your spirits
and wines
and licensing's associated with that
it's their net profit
what happens is that a piece of that
goes to the
substance abuse and alcohol fund
so when you go to slide nine
you're going to see in the table
three um three point two three three
then six
eight eight four ten eighteen point five
so in the earlier years here it was i
think it for three percent
so even before that there was a law that
um basically
said a certain amount of the liquor
revenue should be transferred to this
fund
it had always been suspended and just an
appropriate flat appropriation had been
made
back in 16 um the decision was made to
actually put that law into effect stop
suspending and and allow for what
it was meant to do to occur except they
put it at a lesser percent than
originally
talked about so it was i think it was at
three percent originally
and then in 20 it got up to in the 19
budget i think they bumped it up to 5
it might have been for 19 i can't
remember exactly
but now it's at 5 of their revenue
what throws you off when you look at 21
as you see there's 18.5
in the um house bill 4 which is the
trailer bill to the budget
uh the 2021 budget it was language it
was put in there to
address any shortfalls in the granite
advantage
medicaid expansion fund so if
if there was no if the commissioner
estimated on a
quarterly basis that there was a need
for additional funds they could
request that of the liquor fund and at
this point this year they've requested
an additional 8.5 million dollars
would you just review for the committee
remembers what the granite fund is
the medicaid expansion fund um so
when medicaid expansion was discussed in
the state um
there was a decision made to keep it
very separate from the existing medicaid
and to fund it with um
basically the federal dollars that were
originally 100
match and then as the program moves
forward it becomes less of a match so i
think it's
going to be in like a 90 10 type of
situation eventually i don't know if
it's there yet
but that ten percent that the state's
going to be responsible for whatever the
state's responsible for
it was a desire not to use general funds
so there was a few ways that the state
um tried to get at that one of them was
the insurance premium tax that you saw
discussed
where some of that goes to the granted
advantage so that was
instead of directing that to the general
fund the decision was made if there's
any premiums
um associated with the grant advantage
it would go directly to help fund that
there was also a request
to um and i'm trying to think of the
right way to put this but
basically to have donations from certain
entities
help fund this program um you know to
offset any potential loss
and and then the last budget they
included the liquor funds to help
address any any other shortfalls
so it
because of the the debate and concerns
around what
what this is and how it was set up i i
there's been
a different path of how they try to
shore it up so it doesn't go away
because there's language in the law
it says if for any reason there's not
enough funds
for the program then the state shall
stop doing it
so you know it's always funny to hear
that they don't want to use general
funds so they
when i get it from the electoral fund
but the liquor fund is what feeds the
general fund
yes mr chairman representative
i think that the problem is the federal
statutes
and what controls whether they are going
to contribute or not
um
just for clarification represent me who
contributes
you're muted i thought
i done muted on the federal government
so the fact that the program was set up
with a anticipated matching
so it originally was 100 covered and
then over a period of years it would be
different percentages and i think it
gets down to 90 percent
covered where the state has to match
that with 10 percent
the reason i asked for clarification
because early in the process when the
state started to
have to put up its share
there was an effort to have insurance
companies and
i believe the hospitals make a a
donation kind of a required donation
and that was found not to be allowed
through federal
guidance so they've approached in a
different way and i
and i'm not the best person to be
talking about this i'm
just giving you what i know anecdotally
representative ames and i were involved
in the
original uh figuring out how we could do
this
without losing medicaid altogether
i think or at least the expanded part i
think it was
both of them this is just
this is just so that they don't have to
go back
they don't have to go get an
appropriation
i believe so to
minimize any debate on a general fund
appropriation
because it was clearly stated in the
language in new hampshire's law
related to this that general funds
shouldn't be used
and so the only reason i brought it up
is that liquor commission
when they're coming before the ways and
means committee
it looks like if they just talk about
what they're um
going to deposit to the general fund it
looks like they're losing money
you know if you look back over the years
and so that's why on the earlier slides
they try to show you the total amount
that they're they're generating
and then the legislature has um
decided that a piece of that needs to go
to the
governor's commission fund the alcohol
and substance abuse one
and as well as there's a piece that now
can be used to help shore up the granite
advantage or the medicaid expansion
program
um and the first time you're seeing that
is in fiscal year 21 and it's the 8.5
million of the 10 million
that's transferred to the alcohol fund
that that's where that's coming from
could i ask chris another question
do you know or could you find out is
that
is the current law something that
expires
at the end of this budget and they will
be
redoing something no um
my understanding it's in statute so my
understanding is that it's it's
it there's no repeal date that i'm aware
of at this point
i'd have to confirm that but i'll do
that chris
why is it that we see this
change to 21
but it doesn't appear in 22-23
right because when liquor commission
came before you there was no indication
that um
hhs was going to request any funds they
basically
um are told we need the money by hhs
so anticipation in anticipation of that
question i have reached out to karen
rounds to see if
um if the 8.5 is all they need for
fiscal year 21 at this point
and if there's any uh indication they
might need money in 22 and 23.
does anybody believe that
excuse me never mind i i said does
anybody
believe that oh oh
but so statutorily they need to uh that
the commissioner and the department of
health and human services need to review
the program and and
they provide a report and through that
process that's what drives the
the saying they have a need for this
eight and a half million dollars
can you put that question take this
again for us
about 22 and 23. yeah i actually i i did
that this morning so
yeah it's already with them okay
yes
[Music]
are there any further questions on the
election
mr chairman yes uh just
a comment that we and the liquor
commission are being asked to estimate a
number which
is is quite dependent on
whether the hhs needs to ask for more
money in 22 or 23.
so on well i think we're going to have
to argue out after we get an answer back
from them
whether we decrease what's going to the
general fund in the estimates
or not to match what they've asked for
this year
can you tell me an agency that has an
opportunity to ask for the money
you will not ask for the money
it's on the basis of how many people are
using expanded medicaid
well chris is going to give us a
response
somebody failed administrative policy
when there's money available asked for
it
this is very cynical all
i'm sorry any further questions or
comments on the likely
does anybody have a problem
with taking these as our
numbers for right now until we get
additional information
and we will proceed
i guess uh this is representative ames
yes i'd like to hold on this uh to see
if we can get
better information from dhhs
yes me too okay
we'll do a hold on this yeah normal okay
with holding
fine okay then that's what we're going
to do
on the liquor let's hold it
can we do a lottery next good move
norm can we do a lottery next okay we go
to lottery uh which is
called m on page five you might want to
pull up the water sheet
while he's doing that norm can i make a
comment yes yeah
i talked to charlie mcintyre the other
day
and uh about something else but he i
said geez how did we do this weekend
with the super bowl
on sports betting say that again i had a
conversation with charlie about
about uh something else but then i asked
him
in passing how'd we do with the super
bowl
uh yeah anticipation of
well given that it was tom brady playing
um it was a disaster
the state lost three million dollars
because of so many bets going
to the bucks and in different
combinations of games but
charlie wasn't worried he said this we
knew this was going to happen
because it's the average of the year
that counts in terms of these pools
so uh but i thought that was interesting
to hear that
and the state lost 3 million yeah but
it's a very temporary law i mean you
would think with all the betting going
on for the super bowl that we this would
be a good thing
uh but it depends on how people bet uh
that's why i said remember i said
that there's a risk associated with
because the venues also lost money the
various charitable gaming
are the two to two locations that have
sports book now
also lost money uh on this because
uh there's a risk associated with this
the way it's set up
um and uh but you know it's like it's
like vegas you know over time
you know the house always wins so
the way this is structured we're part of
the house the state is part of the house
these
venues that are running this are part of
the house and uh
i just thought it was interesting that
we lost money on on the super bowl
but uh it's because if brady wasn't
playing
i think it would have been a different
outcome uh but there was
you know a lot of people rooting for
brady and they voted that way
um that's charlie's view as well
on this one but you know it's just an
interesting factoid i i don't think it's
really going to impact our
discussion here but i was just thought
i'd share that with everybody
well thank you that's certainly
interesting
you know it may not hurt norm that we we
get a refresher course on how
from charlie how sports betting
how that all really works um
and uh that's thursday right
well that's well you talking about my
historic racing bill
we could talk about it then until about
i don't want to mix apples and oranges
there but
um but we may have similar conversations
about that
that when that bill is
all heard so we're on the lottery
column m chris
do you have any comments i don't
um i mean you can see that there's been
an uptick in the revenue assumptions
um and i think that charlie indicated a
lot of that is the uh
the mobile and internet aspect along
with the sports betting that has really
helped
and then having those large jackpots
for mega millions and and powerball
okay uh
questions from the committee or comments
if norm this is representative burst
didn't have a question
yes representative bernstein well it's
regarding what what pat
uh what representative abrami just said
and that's that the state lost money
i i always thought that a sports book
adjusts
the odds so if too much money is coming
in
for um for the bucks
then the odds should be adjusted to
incentivize people to put more money on
the chiefs
so the state is not vulnerable or so the
sports book is not vulnerable to losing
money in other words
by the time the game kicks off
the bookmaker once not be all that but a
large portion of it was the fact that
it's
new england so everyone rooted for brady
and whereas draftkings which that's
where the bets are going through they
need to make sure they're balanced
nationally which is a completely
different picture so kansas city
whatever sport books are in kansas city
they made a ton of money
okay it's just a little troubling that
the state of new hampshire can actually
lose money on a proposition where we're
not supposed to lose money you know and
that's why i think
it'd be helpful to to the committee that
we hear
charlie i think specifically come in to
talk to us about
how how that all works we will have that
happen
thank you
any further explanation questions
comments on the
lottery
you don't want to uh hold the lottery
until we
talk to charlie no
we're okay you're okay
i think he's he's he tends to be
moderate
unlike our previous people he tends to
be moderate about his estimates
and he was building it in so we will go
with
lottery yes yes
okay there's no nose that i say
i want to nominate securities revenue
carries on column j on page five
can you bring that up chris yep
you should you see it right yep
we do now yeah just took me a second to
switch screens
everything seems it's instantaneous but
it's not quite
so just uh before you jump into the
securities do you want me to invite
charlie to come talk to you about sports
betting
on the 16th or no yes
you do okay
i don't see any reason not to take the
agency's estimate
that's the last page of their
presentation
are you bringing up the securities page
oh i'm sorry no
it's the last page of their presentation
so what i'm going to bring up is what he
provided you last week
yes
maybe
you know that's it so so this page is
essentially the same as the
the one you got the week before what he
provided you uh
mr glennon provided you an update of uh
it was through 131 2021
the one i think in the earlier
presentation was just through december
and he just wanted the committee to see
that they had gotten some revenue that
at that time wasn't showing
but his projections did not change down
over here
in the lower right hand side
which is made up of the investment
advisors fees security registration
certificates and the bail bonds
and that's been usually pretty
predictable
representative uh hacking phillips
hey mr chair i just wanted to say that i
feel pretty comfortable with these
numbers i'd like to make a motion to
accept as presented
i think the updates we received last
week
does further substantiate their
estimates and i do feel comfortable
anybody not agree with that
all right then let's move on
well i think we're down to the dra of
the dra
ones now uh let me see
the dra is the real estate
why don't you go through the sheet from
uh a to beta
business taxes we haven't done meals in
rooms we haven't done
um
[Music]
interesting dividends we haven't done
let's do red first it's on that page
with the others that we've already done
yeah real estate transfer we haven't
done i think those are the five majors
so i can check it off
on that page okay
okay we are uh let's discuss these
and it's been suggested in real estate
first and the agency
has come in with a high and a low on
each one of these taxes
any questions or comments on the real
estate
well currently the norm uh yeah i think
most of the uh
boom this phenomenon of all these folks
moving into new hampshire
uh bidding up bidding up the prices of
the
of these properties uh and that's
what's reflective in the 2021 number
um and then it appears the dra is
is assuming that that trend will not
continue
i mean it's it's really well above
they're projecting a range of 187
million to 193
on 194 million for 20 21
and then they backed that they backed
that down a bit
over the next couple of years and again
the only thing i can remember from the
conversation it
was this bubble if you will of people
moving out of the cities
coming coming to new hampshire and
there's bidding wars i think none of us
will disagree with that
that that's what's got been going on
but the question is will that continue
um
and it looks like the dra is saying no
that that's that's going to
kind of step itself back to more normal
conditions that's my that's my read so
others weigh in on that
uh representative followed by
representative spillsbury
sorry i believe that representative
tudor had his hand up first
and then me and then uh rep spokesperson
southwood um okay on my screen
it shows the authority
okay i am a little concerned and i've
been trying to find it in my notes but i
remember
reading it again over the weekend
on that the new hampshire housing
finance
authority reported that
on of the people that were buying
housing last year uh from uh
january to october of of 20
on no to august of 20 which does contain
the first
part of the pandemic impact
that on i think it was 16
18 of the people buying were
resident in massachusetts but only one
percent
anywhere else outside the state and that
eighty percent of the of the purchases
were from inside new hampshire i would
really like
to see data on uh what that looked like
in previous years do we really have the
influx that we think we have or
have we kind of built it up and do they
have any more recent numbers
chris you think we can get that
i can reach out to the new hampshire
housing finance authority to see what
they have for information
okay
representative spillsbury right
i i'm comfortable with the idea that
there's a clear
increase anticipated for fy 21.
uh from the connecticut river valley
side where i'm at
i'd say it's been a discernible pattern
but not as great as
a national and general press suggests at
least here
but my bigger question is
given the the measurable
increase that we've seen more or less
since july august
by the way i've looked at real estate
sales in our town and surrounding towns
and there were closings in march
uh maybe early april based on contracts
already in place
the market then died for three to four
months
it wasn't until august that it was
rekindled
um there have actually been very few
sales
they've generally been at five to eight
thousand dollars over asking price which
is
truly a positive indicator but
i think the most noticeable thing is how
few properties are on the market
now i actually think that bodes well
because i think that the psychological
impacts
of the pandemic are going to hold for a
few years anyway
and i think that there will be more
homes on the market
and more homes available to transact so
my question is actually not
whether we're over estimating
it's that i think based on what's
happening
in 21 even with limited availability
it's not likely to dip as much as this
forecast suggests
in 2023
okay representative thomas
that's southworth uh i'm sorry
oh i'm sorry about that um yes just as a
follow-up
seems to me they made a pretty good case
that the availability
is going to just be a really tight
market just because
of you know new homes and all the other
factors related to availability
so i guess i'd like to hear more from
them about that
but it just seems like that's really a
big part of that drop
for the next two years is there just
aren't going to be enough places
available
to keep pace
representative tudor
yeah my regulation was the same as
representative southwest that the
inventory was going to dry up and that
was what was going to drive the real
estate taxes down in the out years
okay representative
of brawny followed by representative
hack and phillips
michael phillips who's next norm
her handle was the first okay
representative
so mr peter's been waiting oh
and tutor is there too right
should i go ahead mr chair yes thank you
um so just um as someone who practices
real estate law
who was very busy last year um between
march and um really the end of the year
we did notice a slight dip for
residential and commercial closings
um in late april but i i should say that
our overall
experience was pretty steady throughout
the year um
the other issue i'd like to just bring
up is that i know the 20
fiscal year 21 numbers were 100
above their plan according to the
folks who presented but they did mention
that anomalous
holding company activity that they
did not believe would continue at the
same rate so that may also
help explain why 21 seems to be
exponentially higher and that they don't
anticipate to see that in 22-23
okay you know at the end of january the
real estate transfer tax
and that reflects the december activity
to july to december is up
about 25 percent from plan
it's really hot for the last six months
now how long will it remain that way
i do know i have a grandson that
he's come back from his third deployment
he's got a couple kids and he's trying
to buy a home
and at least when he looks at
his outbid and it isn't good by five or
ten million uh
five or ten thousand dollars a lot more
than that
in the area that we live in so
it's still hot
representing tomorrow
well let me know you don't have your
hands up sorry about that
representative i mean
yeah um i i recall i think one of our
experts that we had
uh one of the economists uh talked to
this issue
about what's going on and i remember
asking the question well
supply and demand and i said well geez
this seems like a great opportunity
for bill you know invest you know for uh
developers
builders to build more
residences and he but he gave me a lit
he gave us all a litany of reasons why
that's not happening um
you know the prop you know just the land
cost themselves
the uh the lack of uh tradesmen uh there
was a variety of
of things that uh and i don't have that
right in front of me but
um so there there were other people who
were saying yes that
you would think that it'd be more
construction because there's plenty of
demand
and with more demand the pricing would
come down a bit
but um again that's that's all i want to
say on that
i think there's just a phenomenon going
on here uh
that's pushing up the prices and again
let's let's
discern maybe we need to get maybe we
need to get those numbers in front of us
i think the number of transactions may
not be as
what's driving this it's just the cost
it's the price of the homes
and other properties that are driving
this right
because it is the cost right we will be
we will be getting somebody else from
the real estate that
understands the the economy
for real estate to talk to the committee
again try to do that before the 23rd
represent elmi
thank you mr chairman i believe that was
ben frost
on that was talking about that i've been
involved in our local housing market
for 20 years now with bankers and
and a number of other people and talking
with the developers
and it's gotten worse and worse and we
really
are in the situation now where on
housing under 300 000 is pretty much
impossible to to create and profit by
in what the builders consider a
reasonable profit
on without some kind of subsidy
from from the governments the federal or
the
or the state and uh
but that's where most of the demand is
in in my community um which some people
think
is wealthy we have very few homes above
000 they're starting to get there now
because of
the incredible demand for these things
but there are
not that many people that can afford to
bid up that
at that level whereas the house is above
000 uh the prices just keep going up and
people keep paying them
on but we don't have that many people
with incomes that can
do that except coming from out of state
maybe
so i'd really love to see those out of
state numbers
going back and forward
the if you go back to the
slide that one right there
that is what's going on now at a very
steep right
since the pandemic i know i mean you
could easily buy a home
in my area last year earlier last year
before the pandemic for 250
000. now you can't touch anything for
350.
that's a big jump
it shows it in this chart
and people that live in houses that they
bought for 250 don't want to sell for
350 because they can't no they won't be
able to afford
their next house yes
i believe representative ulri was up
first
well i don't see his hand okay
i must have been i must have been
confused then um
uh when we look at these these charts
that have such a meteoric rise like this
and we go back and we look over our
history of the housing market
isn't anybody afraid of a bubble going
on
definitely because we're not talking
about that and when we're looking at
projections of revenues
maybe we should think about that a
little bit
well it certainly looks like the dra
does
so
you're right you've got to keep that in
mind
because that happens that happened but
the 2008
time frame
uh representative anything else
this no sir that was my comment thank
you very much
rather than early do you have your hand
up
oh i see yes i do
no big deal um following up on what uh
herschel had just said regarding the
potential of a bubble let me tell you
what's happening on the collection side
of there's a horde of
refinancing taking place uh from people
who couldn't afford their original
because the
interest rates are so low but with the
interest rates being so low
more and more people are buying above
their means
like they did in 2008 and
because of the new
policy uh issued by the uh
by the fed more and more people are
going to qualify
even though they can't afford even a
modest two thousand or
or three thousand dollar home modest
three
hundred thousand dollar home give me a
break
but i'm really concerned because i know
that
my side the collection side has been
relatively busy even throughout the
pandemic
with warnings of you know guys you got
to pay attention to what's happening
this will end at some time and the
number of people i'm visiting
in new hampshire is really
large so just following up on what
representative nunes had to say thank
you sir
other members of the committee takes
that warning from you
nunes and the dra
representative
thank you on what uh
representative willary said on remind
reminded me we really ought to try and
get some information on how many of
these
are refinancings are
or how many mortgages are fixed
rate versus negotiable because if
they're fixed rate
these people probably will be able to
continue to afford
but if they're negotiable they're going
to run into trouble
representation
thank you mr chairman um i agree with
what
representative almy just said i was
thinking the same thing that
if they're locked into 30 years or 25
years whatever their term
is it's it's less likely to create a
problem
one of the problems in 2008 uh was that
there's several
there were several things going on then
that aren't going on now
at least not yet one is interest only
loans
which totally you know people would pay
just the interest for five years or so
and then all of a sudden they'd be hit
with the real mortgage
and and sadly wouldn't be able to afford
it so you had interest only loans
you had um something called undocumented
loans
where they basically you could get a
loan based on a credit score
um there's so all the there's and
there's other factors that just made it
so easy to get a loan
so even though prices are up people are
paying maybe they're paying too much
but i don't think it's quite the same
bubble at this point
because it is more it is more stable
it's not to say it's not a bubble but
it's not as bad a type of bubble as we
had in 2008 for the reasons i just
mentioned
and one other reason we didn't mention
was the variable rate loans
exactly that was a disaster yeah
representative spellsbury yeah uh
representative gennadian's point i think
is absolutely right on the money
but the other element is the
fallout of 2008 was reaper
repercussions for developments that were
accumulating over five to ten years or
more
and they were all based on loose credit
criteria
and this current environment is based on
low interest
okay it represented do you
have your hand up or yeah the the
refinancing that
i'm participating in is for a fixed rate
and
uh there are some some of them are
exceeding
the 30-year because of the flexibility
that the pandemic has allowed but
they're all fixed rate and they're all
from
uh lenders your your loan depot etc
uh that's only one uh there's
about half a dozen of real subprime
dealers that work in this market
that uh have a huge number of holdings
and they're backed by the larger banks
but they're all fixed rate
so the banks could be in trouble
well yes and no what they what they
learned from 2008 was
the we don't need to hold these we'll
create
a company that is set up to fail to hold
these
and then they sell them amongst the
banks that are going to fail that are
set up to fail to isolate
the primary bank that is that is uh
backing
uh the initial um loan and
quite honestly um they're pushing to get
these things paid
and a lot of people are very happy to
you know get a a three percent loan
uh when they had a five percent subprime
loan and
that's where the issue is going
regarding
building a bubble is that they're still
giving this extra money out
but then and that money is not going to
affect the banks i don't believe
as much as it will affect the entire uh
structure of the subprime
banks that are going to
suffer the stings and arrows of no money
coming in
representative spillsberry just one
further observation in my part of
uh the state uh real estate values have
still not recovered
the levels that they were at at 2008 and
before
you know i don't remember what part of
the state you come from
uh i'm in charlestown connecticut river
valley
about halfway between keene and lebanon
you know where it is i just didn't know
where
you live yeah it's uh it's still a very
weak market here so
send people our way
i'm not going to let anyone go from the
north country
i'm glad you asked that question
representative
tucker
further questions or comments on the
real estate
so that's definitely a hold
yeah i put my hand up uh norm
yeah um this has been an interesting
discussion and
serious issues have been raised around
perhaps some kind of bubble phenomenon
that's very different from
the prior disastrous bubble
that we had so
i don't know whether this is going to be
problematic but certainly serious
questions have been raised and
i hope that we'll be getting in
somebody new new hampshire housing
finance authority maybe
best to speak to these questions
we will and i'm going to try to do that
so
before the 23rd good thank you
representative yes i think
that maybe dean christian would be the
best
for this discussion of
is is there a bubble forming i think
would
probably uh
if we've talked about a lot of different
angles of this
but or if if mr
davido is is recovered
and been keeping up
perhaps he should address it as well
we will work on getting somebody
okay why don't we go to if we do
backwards the tobacco attacks
and if you could put that up on the
screen
yep
it represents me
i didn't realize my hand was still up
is chris going to uh put something up
put the high end roll up
are you not seeing my screen yes
yeah i just had to move my um
participant screen because it was
blocking
the titles so i just moved on to the dra
high and low estimate sheet and i got
the tobacco tax
highlighted and you can see the percent
changes in 22 23 compared to
21.
any questions or comments mr chairman
on starting from
the there are a couple of issues that
we've got to deal with i think from the
vaping side do we have any
data on how much vaping is still
going on in in the
pandemic and
the vaping tax is extremely low so i'm
not sure
if they if they gave us the data for
that we could see but
because that is one of the things that
we thought would be reducing
the amount of smoke normal smoking which
has a normal cigarette tax
attached to it um and then
the second thing is the menthol
cigarettes and
where massachusetts seems to be going
with that if we're going to to actually
lose that
or not and what percentage
of the of the increase
we've seen uh
is actually uh
at risk from them going back to buying
it in
massachusetts we never had a really good
idea and i don't know if we can get one
of on how many of the people who were
smoking menthol were already coming to
new hampshire from massachusetts to buy
cigarettes because our cigarettes are
cheaper
and and then the third of course is the
addiction
uh i don't know if we could find out if
the medical profession has some kind of
handle or
tobacco-free kids or somebody has the
cancer society has some kind of handle
on what's happening during the
pandemic have people on going
back slid to produce
this increase that we've had for
for the new people the tobacco tax has
always been going down because people
have been
moving to to vaping or they've been
moving
to to chewing candy real hard
chris on the uh other
tobacco products that's about six
percent of the total
tobacco revenue is
um let me pull the dra presentation they
might have a
percent breakdown and then
vaping is part of the other tobacco
products right
and then so that
yes if that is six percent
and you have cigars and
other type of tobacco products and they
have friendly snow right
i don't think we were given on
any breakdown of the different kinds of
other tobacco products
there's only they must have it for
vaping but i'm not sure they have it for
the rest
i just looked at the presentation and i
don't see it
so do you see my um
screen yes so the other tobacco products
are six percent
on that pie chart they showed you all
right
do we have any idea of them
percentages that like vaping make up of
that
no
mr chairman could we might be able to
get some information
out of the anti-cancer coalition
that works on this um
i could try and and
contact them and see if if they think
they have something it would only
they they work from surveys in schools
and uh usually
uh their their information on children
is better than on anybody else but
see what you can get because i'd like to
see
since we started taxing
two types of tax on it is
how much have we been collecting and how
is it growing
representative tucker yes i just wanted
to make a comment about the mentholated
uh sales and i i personally don't think
that massachusetts will reverse itself
because the they're two groups of people
primarily apparently that buy
mentholated cigarettes
it's youth who sort of cover up their
early dislike of what actually
smoking feels like because the
mentholated makes it less
harsh and then there's a very political
issue
of that the black and brown populations
are drawn to and targeted as
the people who are
being asked to buy the advertising
and the work of the tobacco companies is
to have black and brown populations
go towards mentholated cigarettes and
that's a very political issue
that quite frankly doesn't exist in
new hampshire but it certainly does in
massachusetts so i personally
uh no particular expertise but i don't
believe that massachusetts will make it
possible to buy mentholated cigarettes
in massachusetts because of the
particular populations that are being
targeted
and i think it's unfortunate that new
hampshire
is counting on those revenues
we hadn't counted on them it was a nice
surprise though
it's just unfortunate yes
i don't i there's nothing more to say
it's just unfortunate
okay representative romney yeah the
two things um okay let's make sure
microphone was off
i was on um yeah two things uh the
uh on the mental cigarettes uh
whether something is going to change in
massachusetts
we can have research take a look at any
they can quickly
review bills that have been filed in
massachusetts at least in the short run
to see if there's any movement there
whether it's jennifer or just use
regular the research office to
to do that for us to reverse this mental
tax uh because i'm sure they've noticed
they've
that the taxes went down quite a bit for
them but again massachusetts is much
bigger than us so
may not be as big a deal so um
that was that and then in terms of the
their projections
dra i mean clearly it was a step
function
with menthol cigarettes i think none of
us are going to debate that that that
occurred
and then from that point which really
changed our base up
quite a bit maybe by you know 40 million
or something
but we've with the rh projecting out
years
uh 22 and 23
as slight reductions from that uh
continuing their
the the normal reduction in the amount
of cigarette smoking that is going on
uh in our state as well as nationally so
i'm comfortable with the numbers here i
mean i i have no problem waiting
uh to vote on all of the tobacco of the
dra revenues in one at one time
but uh but i i think i don't think we're
going to change
much that's here in terms of the way
they've estimated
unless we find that some other variable
that we we missed
so uh i'm willing to reach out unless
chris wants to do it
i can reach out to jennifer to see if
massachusetts is anything in the hopper
that would
reverse their policy on this or their
statutes on this
uh if you want me to do that mr why
don't you
reach out to jonathan okay thank you
representative
oh i think the orders changed
representative spellsbury followed by
representative bernstein
and mr chairman i believe representative
chenegan was before me
i don't know what what happens here
there's supposed to be an
order and he was on the top but then
i'll keep it brief
i just let me keep track representative
major
yes okay uh simple observation
might take away from the testimony last
week
was that they would have predicted or
forecast a three to six percent decline
but because of the surprise the
massachusetts rub off
their zero to three percent down so
computing it that pleasant surprise is
worth about three percent of the total
sounds good uh who's the next
one on the list i believe representative
burstein
thank you uh just in response to
representative abrami's question
there is an act in the um
in the massachusetts senate to repeal
the prohibition of menthol cigarettes
that's significant that's significant
that statement
yeah i i would much rather see new
hampshire send lobbyists
to maine and vermont get them to pass a
similar ban
anyway i i still think you should have
jennifer look into it uh
maybe she can find some other
information about it that's all i got
thanks and how does the speaker feel
about it
because it's they act differently than
new hampshire
everything in new hampshire all the
bills have to go to the floor
but in other states if a speaker
doesn't care for it it never sees the
way today
[Music]
say it was a senate bill or house bill
senate village uh bill xce 554
and then the senate president
it probably is the senator probably
would not have put it in
the senate president wasn't on board
the next speaker representative
yes i was just wondering general
question the six percent
other in the um tobacco chart uh pie
chart there
do we have any information on how that
is that six percent
is that number growing is the other
number growing i guess is the question
yeah you just passed
it was the pie chart with the six
percent other
yep so i just put i'm putting up the bar
chart so this is their other tobacco
products and you can see
the rates that have been associated with
that and then where
the the bar is going over the last few
years
so since 14 the rate has been at the
65.03 percent
and you can see it it's trending
slightly upward
so it accounts for you know about back
in
16 it was just over 10 million and now
it's just over 16 million of the
the total pie of your um tobacco
okay so so the other has grown to six
perc
six percent presumably if that trend
continues it'll be
seven percent and eight percent well
knowing that in those years the total
tobacco revenue
has been dropping an average of three or
four percent
so the other is taking a bigger
percentage
okay thank you representative southworth
uh thank you um i think i can support
the agency's estimates i think
for 2021 they've taken into account the
kind of increases due to vaping
the menthol issue and the covet issue
and i'd agree with uh
representative abrami that i think then
they've gone back to
the long-term trend that it's going to
just keep dropping off each year
representative almighty
thank you on i would like to
hold this one until we've had a chance
to
to ask the people in the anti-tobacco
industry where they see things going
right now
we're going to hold it
and i'll contact mike rolo and talk
uh president that's pat you know you may
want to ask him as well
that they usually monitor legislation in
other states as well
if they have a beat on what's going on
with that bill
in massachusetts
that senate bill
he of course wants us to kill tobacco
oh no but they would have knowledge of
what of all yes that's
true you know thanks i'll ask him that
representative ames
okay uh yeah
i just wanted to chime in and support uh
holding this uh i i don't know that we
can get better data but i i was looking
while we were
all talking at um
[Music]
reports from massachusetts on what's
going on from their perspective they're
losing a lot of money
on this issue not just in new hampshire
but to
other surrounding states so it's a it's
a hot topic and
the fact that there's a senate bill is
interesting and
i don't know whether we're going to be
able to get a better handle on this
usually you can't when you're talking
about something that's
political like this but um but
let's see if we can get a little further
down that road before
making judgments all right then why
don't we move on
to we have two you have one more
question
oh there is okay senator burstein
yeah thank you uh just one more data
point on this and that's the sponsor of
the bill in massachusetts
is the assistant minority leader
yeah um if that gives you any indication
on on how much that it does oh yesterday
yes they have a minority of two don't
they
thank you representative bernstein
all right we have two revenue streams
left we'll go to the meals and roams
and save the business taxes to last
so chris if you bring up the yep
and just to remind the committee mr
summers from the new hampshire lodging
and restaurant association will
speak to you on the 16th at 10 am
you would ask me to reach out to the
association to see if somebody to talk
about what's going on with
at least give you a sense of what's
going on with the restaurants
particularly those small smaller
restaurants that might be closing
even if it's temporarily you know what's
the impact on long term and and what do
they foresee
um in terms of you know the pandemic and
its long-term impact on on
restaurants as well as the lodging in
the state
and i'll just bump it over to the dra
high low so you can see the
percentage changes that they were
estimating for meals and rentals
and then if you want i can bring up
their presentation from the other day
just let me know if you want that
um why don't we go with this for right
now
okay
okay the first one occur
yes this is the probably the area where
the
when we think that the normalcy will
come from so-called
herd immunity and really getting
the pandemic behind us is probably the
most important
so i'm eager to to hear from someone
as to when we think that's going to
happen
i watched most of the presentation
uh at finance on the pandemic
and it really had to do with
vaccinations and one thing or another
they did not deal with
i didn't watch the last 15 minutes but
uh they didn't deal with when they think
we'll really
have new hampshire reopened
to things that would involve meals and
rentals tax and i think the
spread is such that we do need to get a
grasp of that
it was clear to me that people in the
theme park business they haven't issued
when they plan to open
they haven't issued uh they haven't
hired people for the summer
people really don't know what's going to
happen in the tourist season for the
summer which is so important in new
hampshire
so if we could get if we could hold this
until we get some idea
of what people who know about herd
immunity think
i think would be useful
okay next representative abrami
yes uh maybe a good idea i mean
logic of restaurants are 80 of this rev
review stream 17 18
is lodging i think there's also a
lodging association isn't there
um is that correct norm i think there is
a lodging association
yes we can have maybe we can have them
come in on the same day
as uh the restaurant association
they're the same thing aren't they right
is the restaurant and lodging is that it
yeah yeah mr summers represents the new
hampshire um
lodging and restaurant association okay
so there we go
and and i asked him um to address both
aspects um okay
during the presentation right um
and especially what i've asked him for
is is uh to give you a sense of
what they've been seeing right now with
with restaurants and
lodging what they project in the short
term and then the long term
short term down the road and then longer
letting him know that the committee is
trying to get a sense of
how do they how do you think fiscal 21
is going to end and then you got to
project into 22 and 23.
so um i may have a few more questions
from him but i think he's got a sense of
what you're looking
for this is this is going to be the
tough
this is going to be the toughest one i
think that and rotol
when we get to to that highway fund
these are going to be the two toughest
ones to project thank you
representative southworth uh thank you
i agree with everything that's been said
so far
um i'd like to delve into a little bit
what might happen with the bars
and um i just wonder in new hampshire if
again we'll go up and down they'll open
there'll be a spread
then they'll close i'm just not sure how
smooth it will be
i got taken at a restaurant on saturday
it was
packed there wasn't a single person
wearing a mask because they were eating
but the place every table was full every
chair
and i can't imagine you know with what
we know
that that's not going to cause issues
also when we get below
age 50 i think we're going to have more
people who do not get vaccinated
so i just think it's very tricky and
look forward to the presentation
was this restaurant in new hampshire
yeah
i think the tables might have been six
feet apart
but still for me to see you know over 60
people
even with the table six feet apart not
one person had a mask because they were
sipping their coffee or whatever
it had to be a super spreader from my
position
because not many people have had shots
and i have a feeling this is not unusual
okay the next one representative nunes
thank you very much uh mr chair um
i just want to to have make a couple of
statements concerning this
uh you know we're we're still currently
dealing with moderated customer access
in the restaurants and lodging
of those businesses because of the
emergency orders that are still in place
another another point is that there are
many businesses that have closed their
doors and
we're still seeing drops in revenue
because of business closures
uh people that are struggling and they
just can they're finding out week after
week that they just can no longer make
it we need to keep that in mind
i also wanted to just give a little side
note here my mother-in-law went skiing
when we had the big storm that came
through and
she said it was really difficult at the
slopes because of the restrictions that
were there
it it was very frustrating for customers
and that the conversations that she had
with other people is that they weren't
going to be going back because it was
too difficult
they had to stand in line for the
restrooms only one person
at a time and i'm just giving you guys
some some leads in
on on what we're seeing out there um and
that you were you were you were timed
inside the restaurant you could only be
in the restaurant for 30 minutes
uh and uh the the spacing
that they had outside for people to
stand to get on the lips
just made it really difficult and they
all had to traverse a long way just to
get to a lift and she said
we're not going back this year uh until
we figure out what's going on
as we move out of situations like that i
think we have to look at what's going to
happen
i think things will lighten up again in
the summertime just as they did last
summer
and what happens if future restrictions
are applied
and we when we move out of the summer
months into the cold months again
as we have different strains of the
virus that are coming out that will be
looked at by our people in charge up
there making
making the decisions about emergency
orders
this is all going to have a big effect
on on
the the possibilities of gauging a
revenue stream for
rims and meals and i think that we have
to take a very conservative approach
and i agree that we need to hear a
little bit more
the next one representative almighty
thank you on i think
we're going to have yeah i i agree we
have to take a conservative
approach with this i do not see
how we're going to be able to get good
information on how
the covid pandemic how long it's going
to go
on with the variants coming in
and on i've been listening to
some pretty scary stuff about if we
don't get people vaccinated
in time on the variants are going to be
proliferating or if we don't get the
people in
africa vaccinated in time they will
bring back variants
that may be resistant to our
to our vaccines and
on what it will get away from us again
i'm not sure i think we need
need medical experts outside of
the state to talk to us at this point
the state government
because on i was listening to their
presentation to hhs
at the time that they gave it a couple
of weeks ago and
they were sure that they were going to
be able to
um move everybody that needed a second
shot to a totally separate system and
leave room
for people who needed a first shot to
get a little bit closer to the beginning
of 1b
uh it looks at this point i mean
that didn't work it's been quite a mess
they're struggling to make it work
and once they've got it working
hopefully it will help things
but if we don't get enough people
vaccinated
before the variants start spreading
which they are already doing spreading
across the country
fairly rapidly at this point then
we're going to have a much harder time
controlling this epidemic
that we for that we need people from the
medical
profession that are not uh
not obliged to toe the party line
and not party sorry on
the the state establishment line
and we can get this done
chris chris yep
how are we doing and getting hhs
or somebody that's a expert
in the vaccine coming before the
committee
um i'm still waiting for them to clear
somebody from
to schedule with us i'm not sure we're
going to get somebody i mean that
i've been dealing with john williams and
abigail
and i forget her last name right now but
they were pretty sure we wouldn't be
able to get dr chan so they were trying
to see who else would be available
i gave him the date to the 16th and the
18th to try to schedule somebody
um i had no luck scheduling the other
two doctors that were mentioned
dr calderwood and dr mercado
um i think i forwarded that information
back to the committee
um they didn't have time available to
come and meet with you
um i i don't know what to suggest
or provide for information other than
that at this point i have nobody
to come in and discuss this issue with
you maybe there's something interesting
with hhs but
i'm sorry um
let me make a couple calls
would we be able to solicit something in
writing
maybe from the cdc from their latest
bulletins on where they think things are
going
we need to be able to have a
question and answer session with the
committee so they understand what this
what the time tells but meanwhile maybe
we all could be looking for things that
would be useful to the whole committee
i haven't seen really anything but
perhaps if we all keep our eyes open to
possible stories we need to understand
this
it's very important so
we've got to move it off dead center so
let's see i'll talk to you chris
yep who's next
representative ames okay thank you
um yeah i just wanted to say that i
uh wholeheartedly with what
representative nunes put forward and
then others have chimed in
um this is this is a really difficult
uh source of revenue to estimate and
it's also true i i would add
for the business taxes which we haven't
discussed yet but they're affected by
this uh uh covet phenomenon also
um i do think we should get what
information we can but each of us
is you know we're doing that uh i'm sure
everybody is reading and searching for
good information there's no guru out
there that's going to tell us
what the case is going to be a year from
now we're going to have to make
judgments about that
and so back to representative nunez's
comment i i myself plan to be
uh cautious on this conservative uh
in my estimating uh knowing that
um there is a big piece that is going to
affect revenues in a significant way
that
is unpredictable so we just have to make
the best judgment we can
that's my contribution i look forward to
whatever information that can be
for the committee and i'll keep poking
away and then we'll make a judgment
next representative spillsberry
right so this is so inherently unknown
and that's baked into the range
of forecasts we've gotten which is why
representative james was inclined
the range is especially large with the
business tax and the meals and rental
stats so
while i'm completely open and open
minded want to hear as much input
as possible i think this is so
unknowable
what we should do is simply go for the
most conservative end of the range
and then any upside is not counted on
it's just a blessing
thanks there are no more
all right so this is
we're gonna hold this until we can get
some more information
the last is the business taxes for today
i think we also have not covered
interest in dividends
[Music]
that is right
you are right let's go to the business
taxes
and then interesting
so i've got on the general fund
education trust fund worksheet page it's
the
first column in your worksheet um
remember that the the
fy 2021 revenue numbers on a cash basis
are actually 30 million dollars higher
than what you're using for your base and
the reason was there was money that was
collected in 21
that was attributable to fiscal year 20.
so i just want to
just remind you of that and it so it's
already backed out of the numbers that
you have before you
in terms of the cash basis when you're
looking at the revenue focus
if you look at what's been collected to
date
by year to date it's going to be higher
because there's a line at the bottom of
the table that subtracts that 30.8
million
so for business taxes it's 18 million
but for all the other revenue so i've
had that we've backed out those um those
numbers
um i mean i don't have anything to say
about the business taxes i think you
you're all
alluding to the issues and it's there's
a lot going
on and that could impact your taxes one
way or another
um you know as it relates to the
pandemic as it relates to
businesses that are slowed down as a
part of it
as part of the pandemic others that are
accelerated as part of the pandemic and
and where that lands in terms of your
business taxes is uh
uh this is why it's hard to project
this is why we need to get somebody that
will
bring us up to date on the status of the
vaccinations and the pandemic
pandemic as a whole we don't understand
that
then we
[Music]
yes thank you um so through january
we're 78.5 million ahead of plan the
plan that was developed two years ago
three years ago
so that's a good sign uh but we all know
that we're waiting
the real real test is going to be
what the estimates are going to be
coming in at uh in march and april
what comes in when people file their
final tax return so just want to remind
everybody of that
but right now it's looking pretty good
my sense is that and again we got to
remember upside down chart that most of
this
business taxes come come from the large
companies
my sense is that a large a lot of these
larger companies are weathering this
storm pretty well
and we have a lot of manufacturing
producing pieces that go into other
products
that they sell you know around the
country
so i you know yeah
i think this one's going to be a little
easier to estimate than
than women meals tax
and obviously the dra
is
a bit optimistic as well when you look
at when you look at
their estimates um again
we know a lot of the small businesses
have been hurt
uh but again a lot of them didn't even
pay
these taxes maybe some bet
but so i you know i think this one won't
be as difficult as
as interest and rumor males uh
to to estimate unless there's some major
catastrophe that
unforeseen catastrophe that will
impact these larger companies but right
now as of this moment it looks like
they're weathering it pretty well and
these are the companies
we rely on that's all i had to say on
this
thank you and if you do look at the
revenue focus
it shows 78 million in the head it's
really
60 million because of the
if you look at down below
right i uneven should have gone and 18.2
million it
comes out of that right
30.8 million 18.3 million
is business taxes that are bringing it
out of 60
right who's next
representative
yeah thank you
uncertainties uncertainties so um
we've got a whole lot of variables
feeding into this one
that carry uncertainties one is uh
current law where there are changes that
are going to impact
uh revenues the market market-based
sourcing single
sales factor both of those are baked
into the
current upcoming law and we've got to
deal with them
uh hard as that will be and um
as uh representative brownie has pointed
out we don't know yet
how revenue is going to come in this
year and we've got some
significant inputs that are going to
happen
soon but not soon enough uh
and i mean that in terms of our ability
to estimate we'll get them a little
a little bit late in this budgeting
process so there's that
there's the rate question we've got the
lower rate
and we'll get more money out of that and
there are arguments in this committee
for assuming that the lower rate will
lead to more
business revenues i i don't agree with
that
um but uh that i think influences uh
uh judgments on uh on revenue
and so we will need to talk about that
um and uh impacts of
uh various changes in the tax law
both federally and uh
at the state level continue um
foreign dividends for example how will
those change or not change
uh from the level that they've reached
since the enactment of the big federal
change
whatever year was i don't remember
and uh and so um
this is a tough one that's all i can say
and covet on top of that
well there's one thing is when we do our
revenue estimates
it's based on current law
the uh house bill 10 which has to do
with rate
is a separate issue altogether okay
okay who's next representative
alby thank you
on two things first
i'd i guess maybe i better concentrate
on what people have been
talking about recently first on
the the dra essentially
said it can't estimate single sales
factor
but that the indications are that it
will cost us
money but that is based on a totally
different environment than
then it will come into next year
and they they don't have a firm handle
on
on market-based sourcing what that
impact is going to be either
and i don't remember uh them saying
anything about that when they talked
with us before
uh and
on we've they are current law
so i don't know what we're going to do
about that but um
we might uh start
asking them if they included that
it's not in their list of effects
that affect their decisions on this
that were on page 22 of the
january 19 presentation
they gave us
and all of the future outlook
essentially was
coveted related on that one
and um
it's page 22 of of i don't know if
you're in the
next i'm i think you might be
referencing the um
presentation that the first presentation
the week before
yes i have the wrong presentation up i
can bring that one up
okay and
and the the covid part of this is going
to be really
difficult to tell but when he can bring
that up
on the effects that they were looking at
had a lot to do with what the federal
aid was
the federal aid last year
is going to be different from the
federal aid this year they probably
aren't going to be prioritizing the
large corporations
which are the ones that give us our
money
and we i don't know if there's any way
we can find out how that one's
going we could talk to our congress
people
[Music]
and get and get an idea of that maybe
but it's not our current law
i but i think that it's it's part of our
environment that uh they're going to be
changing
their law about and probably
about the large corporations which are
the ones we get
most of our business tax revenue from
and i don't know how that's going to end
oh
none of us do but it was page 22 i was
looking at
yep no i just want i was just bouncing
back to see what they said on page 20.
so the shift in business behaviors all
uh and the federal stimulus money and
all of that came out of covet but it was
the
the first on
first way of looking at it and it was
under a republican administration
and the second way of looking at it is
going to be
under a democratic one
which is more concerned with the smaller
businesses
and with with ordinary
citizens it it'll be
interesting to see what they're doing
and it'll probably
influence our business tax revenues a
fair amount
i don't know what we do about that and
then as you can see the future outlook
is lifted restrictions
vaccine and an improvement in economy
which
i think is dependent on that
representative abrami
another variable uh that we should uh
take into mom
let's there's some there's action in the
senate right now
on the ppp program and whether
uh the uh ppp
uh forgiven money is taxable or not
and uh the senate has a bill that
they're
going to be acting on but we're we're a
non-conforming state
for the new members we don't when the
federal
when the federal law changes in relation
to taxes
many states will say well we'll make
them part of our
our statutes if you will or their
statutes
ours on our state we don't we decided
and we had a lot of discussion in our
committee over the years about this
we we are conforming based on a report
that we get in march
i think it's march from dra as to
whether or not
they list all the the federal tax law
changes
uh and then we make a decision as to
which ones we want to conform to
so right now we're a non-conforming
state and our statutes are 2018 that we
go by
so this is where the rub is right now
the ppp program made a change in their
in the statutes that are
different than what our statutes are
and because in the in the federal
statutes it says specifically under
federal law loan amounts received by
taxpayers from paycheck protection
program
ppp that are forgiven will not be
included in taxable income federally and
businesses
business expenses paid for with forgiven
ppp loans can be deducted
now our our statutes are the same except
in our case uh
uh can be conducted
ours reads under the current new
hampshire bbt statute loan amounts
received
by new hampshire taxes from ppp that are
forgiven
will be included in taxable income for
wptp purposes
and business tax expense paid for
for with foreign ppp loans can be
can be deducted so so
there's a there's a difference in the
business expense uh issue so i don't
want to spend much time on it now but i
think it's something that's going to
come to us
and fairly soon but but when we're
having this discussion
we are not conforming with the federal
law so i would say that
we can continue to project as we are our
business taxes on
what we perceive as current law not on
what the federal government thinks said
you know uh our statute should be
because we haven't adopted
those those the federal uh laws so it's
kind of a complicated thing but i think
it's worth mentioning that there's
something on the horizon that we're
going to all be dealing with
if the senate passes their bill
we will be dealing with it i hadn't
brought it up because we're
dealing with current law right now yeah
but i wanted to but just to
just to complete that is that even
though we don't conform
the federal government our laws does say
that if you use it for what it was
intended
it's at least 60 percent
you're forgiven
and then you can ex expense
the money and then if you use it
all for expenses then there's no taxes
on it
but we'll have that discussion
when the time comes
max representative
thank you i'd just like to correct a
small piece of that well it wasn't so
small
on the senate last year on
avoided completely are our plan
to have a conformity discussed
in march this year on because
they wanted to stick conformity in
various parts of conformity
with the federal law law from 17
in on in the budget
and parts that increased the revenues
or probably would increase the revenues
and they put those into hb4
and they're operating now and they are
current current law
but they did not touch the ppp loans
at that point we've conformed with most
of the things
that were in the fy 17 changes that we
hadn't already decided in the past not
to conform with
but on and i don't
think um i got a letter
on at the end of last year i think
talking about the conformity which i
passed on to representative major
on and essentially there wasn't much
less
left to talk about because the senate
had already grabbed it and insisted on
it being in the budget
camera susan i can't recall but i think
one of the big issues was section 178
and federal law about accelerated
depreciation
yes that one we avoid that won't be did
senate agree with us on that i can't
recall
and they they didn't want to to use it
because accelerated depreciation reduces
your evidence
right right okay so they agreed with us
on that one thank you
yeah and the committee will
get an education on this whole process
of the irs the federal ir
code compared to what we do
and especially when it comes to
a ppp loan and we'll have that when
senate bill 3 comes over but we still
need to stick to the current law
next uh there are no more hands
okay this is a definitely hold
so we need to go now to the
interest and development
which is called e
my
did you want to bring up the uh
the gra sheet on that
well he's doing that interest in
dividend
has been doing good this year we're
about 45 percent have had a plan
to date the big money comes in
in april and they can they could put us
below
the low plan but the bulk of the money
comes in april
so you should see the start of their
presentation on the interest and
dividends
the pie charts showing you um the
breakdown of how
what's paid interest dividends
distributions
individuals versus partnerships in the
states
you've heard mentioned of the the
triangles there's one for the ind as
well so you can see
of the taxpayers generally what they've
paid
not individual with that group let me
interrupt
here this triangle picture showed the
interest and dividend the bet the bpt
you should make copies of this and have
it available to
always refer to but this tells you
who's the major taxpayers here
like the interest in dividend
70 something percent
is paid by a
small percentage of the population or
or 50 percent
50 yeah 50. so let's go ahead yes
and so here's their trending line from
2011 through 2020
and as you can see at the bottom of the
chart they
give you the rate and then they give you
some things that could influence the
revenue
including the economy the stock market
performance interest rates
federal tax reform and money in the bank
were all things that they
identified
and that's um that's all their
presentation at the end is the
the estimates but this is what they um
one of the taxes that they came in
last week and because uh january
did a little bit better than they
expected they revised the
um high point that's the increase to the
135.5
that we discussed at the beginning of
today do you go back to the
one that has the triangle please yep
so
the people who pay
is that we do need to study it i see
that
that's a really interesting term i think
number of people are very high in some
places
but the income is low but then the
income is high from a very few people
so somehow you can see why
not people with modest incomes feel like
they're really hard hit
by the fact that they were frugal
through their lives
and they don't feel like they're rich
because they're not from income sourcing
you have less than two less than three
percent
of the people pay 50 for tax
right and so you have all these people
who
are paying it who have been
who aren't part of a wealthy group and
they are
thought of as wealthy and are being
asked to pay something
in a state where people don't pay much
to the government so it's just a
fascinating chart
and on the fact that it's just a few
people who pay most
we can also focus on the fact that large
numbers of people
who don't have a lot of income are
are paying something and they're feeling
you know
ill used
this chart along with the b and the bpt
uh three very important charts
okay um what's next uh
representative hillary
uh i don't know if everyone is aware but
tennessee did a phased-in
elimination of their ind over the last
four years
i've reached out to some people i i know
in tennessee
on the legislature through alec and i've
asked
for them to provide me with some
information i'm waiting for it
the what i've been told orally not
with documentation yet their phase out
over four years
had no significant impact on their
budget
and it's a much larger budget than that
of new hampshire
so just we'll see what that information
is and just letting you know that
it's uh coming in whenever it gets here
jordan their interest
in dividend tax is what percentage of
the total
it's just it's uh well i
i don't know for sure i'll i'll get that
information and and get it out to you
i just didn't ask that thing but it uh
it's
it's was a significant chunk of money
for the
volunteer state um not as much as jack
daniels gives them but it was still a
significant
significant part okay
thank you mr chairman on
as long as we're on this chart i'm i
want to talk to that
first um but
on the this is very different from the
business profits business enterprise
taxes because those
are based well the profits tax is
based on your income uh
on the on the total income profits
of the uh corporation the entity
that we're taxing whereas in this case
we have wealthy people and poor people
mixed into
the entire to large parts of the
triangle
uh people who are
getting a thousand uh paying a thousand
dollars who have an income
from would have an income from uh
of twenty thousand dollars from
from the interest dividends
distributions and that's all they're
living on
other many many others in that category
would be on wealthy people that put a
little bit of their
their money in interest on
high interest or high dividend uh
stocks and and bank accounts
so on you've it's not really
showing the wealth of the people in
those different sectors until you get
way up in the
in the people someone who's paying 50k
an entity it would be that was paying
50k in taxes
would have uh on
what is it a hundred million no two
two million of of interest
and dividends and distributions
so they are highly unlikely to be poor
people
but and then we've got the people down
at
at twenty dollars of interest up to
to a thousand dollars of interest at the
bottom there
so so that's another way to look at that
chart
it's very different from the other two
triangles
um but interest on
what i'm my question originally was is
that on we were assuming
uh when you look at at the growth
of the intern
you accidentally muted yourself the
growth
sorry the growth of the interest and
dividend stacks
um
[Music]
in the last few years
when they did on they did the federal
end of 17 tax return
tax reform and they
produced an incentive for for not as
much as they thought but
repatriations coming back from overseas
of money to american corporations
and they were um
[Music]
we were assuming that they were going to
be pushing
on part of this the corporations would
put some of this
out and increased on
dividends and i presume distributions
and that it was going to show up and
that's what we
thought we saw coming towards the end of
fy
18 and and especially in fy
19 increasing the tax and
and i believe representative ames was
talking about
it showing up in fy 20 as well
we don't real i mean that should be
dying down at this point but
we don't really know how much it is
thanks representative abrami
yeah just one more point on that uh the
triangle
i think representative romney was
pointing out
so yeah that what it's showing there is
how much tax is actually paid to make
sure no one's confused about that
and that 50k i just said the math so
that would mean that that investor that
that
individual had a million dollars of uh
interest and dividend uh revenue coming
to them for their investments
so five percent of that is 50k so i want
to make sure everybody understands
what we're looking at there so there
really aren't that many people that have
well it looks like 131 people in the
state that have that kind of
uh interest and dividend income coming
to them
and um the other thing is that interest
interest rates are still so low we know
that most of this has to be coming from
dividends uh because
even our treasury is saying we don't
even estimate how much
but we don't really get much in uh in in
interest
from putting our money in the bank but
the stock market's doing well um and the
stock market's been doing well
for for a bunch of years now and it
doesn't seem to be slowing down
and that you know whether that's an
aberration
or uh uh there's a lot of dollars
sitting on the sidelines right now
with people looking for places to put it
so they're putting it in the market
but you know but what really drives
dividends is the company's actually
doing well
uh and that didn't decide to to share
that that
profit with the shareholders
so obviously that's where dra must be
thinking the money's coming from
from that that kind of uh optimism
um that that's just my observations
only 13 of that is from interest
right most is from dividends right
dividend is 40
and distributions as well um it's close
to 40.
which is in other kinds of like the s
corpse and so forth the thing we were
talking about with one of the bills we
had
those distributions
from the company to the individual
partners
is i think what we're talking about
there
or maybe not i mean it's uh
it's just getting money out of the
company giving it to two owners
which a stockholder would be an owner
yeah does distributions also
include on payments to
to the ceo and
other top officers of these corporations
no i think those are handlers they get
huge payments you're thinking of bonuses
i think bonus payments has treated a
salary
right you have to be taxed that way
any other questions um i just have a
question
myself um does that triangle chart
support the bill that wants to raise
the exemption figure
that exemption applies to
all interest and dividends yes that
exemption
right and so that it would affect it
and it would help the people in those
slower brackets is that correct
the most yes okay
over the top of the triangle yes
yeah if i could chime in um
remember that the exemptions apply
generally to everybody
but there are also exemptions for elder
elder taxpayers and for
disabled and blind i think those are the
three kids
they are on and so uh
those exemptions apply across the board
they're very small
we'll discuss them more
we'll look at them closely when we talk
about the bill um
and do our work session on the uh
the proposal to change the exemptions
so if you if you mind if i chime in uh
go ahead so let's use the 500 one
so that to to have to pay to five
five hundred dollars in tax that would
mean that you have had interest in
dividends of
ten thousand dollars so what's going to
happen is
that when we we do if we increase the
exemption that would mean
well depends on how much we do it let's
say let's say we increase the exemption
by 1400
the 1400 comes off to 10 000.
okay it's off of what the actual amount
is
so i guess yes it will help the smaller
the smaller investor if you will
um right right now it's 2400
and if you're a joint that'd be 48
and if you're elderly it would
bring you up to 6 000
and so you'd pay taxes on 4 000 if you
had 10
000 dollars
and if we double that then that
particular one
would not
further questions uh yes uh
representative army
thanks on looking still at this
chart and trying to think about what
distributions really are we've never
really
paid a whole lot of attention to them i
think they were smaller in the past
you know the chart that we were at uh no
the the triangle
oh sorry sorry i thought you wanted to
go back to the pie chart
well that one shows that the
distributions are almost as important as
the dividends
uh at this point i don't think they were
in the past but maybe that's something
to ask
um the
the partnerships
are only responsible for
sorry i need to unmute myself on the
other side because i'm
there we go okay the partnerships are
only
one million dollars total
on that they're contributing so
they can't i mean they obviously are not
contributing a lot to that that 39
of the tax and
[Music]
that leaves individual llc's
i'm not sure i think we need to
to be told told by cpa
where the distributions come from maybe
if we could ask the cpa society
on can you get that uh
chris yep hello
can i chime in do you mind having a
discussion on this briefly here um
go ahead uh again when i filed mine when
i was an owner of an s-corp
remember s-corps are not partnerships
but with
s-corps you file as an individual
the money gets distributed to you as an
individual so when i filed my tax to new
hampshire
was under individual uh
efficient dividends so the real question
is yeah i think we should get
further clarification no question but um
just understand that as corpse
are when you file as a in the state
interest in dividends you're flying as
an individual not as an s corp
so but we'll have some an expert in this
should
should chime in i think the drake dra
could probably explain this very well as
well
that that's who i would start with i
believe just sensitive state tax and how
they would handle
the idea of the distributions yeah i
think they have the answers to those
in fact i think for mr chair
when we when we meet next on this
since all the open questions are on the
uh maybe you're going to do this but
all the open questions are on cra taxes
is that they should be included in the
meeting i would invite them to the
meeting
they definitely will be
that's why we saved them to last
yeah so that's a definite hold
on the interest dividend
yes so we have a hold on the
business taxes loans and meals tax
tobacco tax
liquor tax interest and dividends
the real estate transfer tax
communications
communications also did you say that
hold on
yes yes rather than right hold i
i had a double question mark that is a
hold
did i miss anything
so so we have a busy schedule ahead of
ourselves
but we took care of the easy ones
do one more easy one norm can we do fish
and game and get that done
uh i think highway fund
we may want to have some folks in the
highway fund because of the
we're probably going to have some
discussion we have to do that today but
discussions around
the big the big number there is the uh
rotol
that we is affected by the by the uh
pandemic more than anything else there
so we should i'd like to have the age
it'd be great if we had the agency in
in in with us as we're discussing that
and then uh
but i think fish and game i think we
could yeah we can do
fishing game right now
you want to pull up session game chris
yep
in just a few minutes
my wife is chuckling because i did but i
didn't share the screen so
too small thanks working on it
page 10.
is it better yeah yes that's good
so they look good to me
don't know that we need to spend much
time on them does anybody have any
issues
with the numbers from the fishing game
any issues with the numbers from our
questions relative to the numbers in the
fishing game
looks straightforward all right so
anybody have a problem if we go ahead
and accept the numbers as they are
for this point in time and we will do
that
does anybody else have any questions and
journals
before we close for the day
then we will have
somebody come in and talk to us on the
status of the vaccination
and the pandemic we definitely will have
somebody come in and talk to us on the
housing situation
and the gra will bring them in to
cover the the bulk of the
high running taxes
business meals and rooms tobacco
interest in dividend communication
and real estate
any further questions or comments
well this isn't a question or comment
before we close i'd like to make an
announcement to my caucus
you can and i'll make an announcement to
our caucus right after that
okay great um i think that we ought to
get together briefly if um
at 1 30 perhaps to
to discuss what i sent last night
see if people want to trade and things
like that
thanks okay you're going to set it up
susan
oh we have it's already amanda's room
if she's not she said we could use it
without her actually that's good
okay we have a clock in the republican
caucus at 3
30 and that link has been sent to you
and are you trading too
are you interesting sounding is the
democrats for the training
chairman majors yes that's false just
representative tudor i didn't receive
anything on the zoom meeting today so if
someone could forward that along i'd
appreciate it
uh we will and and this is
representative nunez although i did i
knew about the meeting i didn't get the
link either
you didn't who else didn't get the
length for 3 30.
i wanted you to send it to everybody to
make sure
yeah i sent it to the republican members
of the
ways and means and so maybe i've got two
wrong emails
what i'll do is i'll send it to you
right after what what time is it now
quarter of well my wife is going
for me for lunch so i better go eat
lunch first
and i'll get it out after that the thing
is that we're getting so many
so much mail a charitable uh
there's hardly room in our inboxes for
zoom
invitations
three quarters of it is nashua
send me an email message and i'll reply
to your message with the
link
historical racing just think it could be
speed limits unlike winnipesaukee
that was well over two thousand
that was senate bill 22 my first year i
couldn't believe it but that's okay
i'm glad i'm almost reaching the uh that
uh record number here
norm you may want to just go over what
your plan is for tomorrow and the next
day
with everybody real quick in terms of
executing some bills
what we're going to do right
we're having a republican caucus today
to determine what bills we would like to
exact
tomorrow i'll be in contact with susan
she's already has had a
meeting of her caucus and then the
ones that will be real controversial
we'll save for the next day
we'll try to work them in during the
public hearings
but we'd like to get those easy bills
out tomorrow
representative major yes representative
schamberg here
uh will there be a on-site
lob meeting for these bills or is it
going to be zoom
uh the public caring
that's scheduled for thursday
no no wednesday tomorrow well wednesday
tomorrow is
just as soon
okay
about thursday and then thursday
i'm going to plan on being in
my own home and i don't know okay
is anybody else going to be at the lobby
not if you're not going to be there
norm i'm debating whether or not one of
us should be there
the reason why i made that decision is
that
how do you expect if people
you people can't hear us from the room
and they
present and you can't understand the
presenters
and you can't understand each other why
even has a meeting in the first place
so that was bad it's like
we do a pretty good job communicating
this way
plus you shouldn't be there
oh that's what my wife tells me for
tomorrow's exact other people do
tomorrow's execs do you have to have
people's pictures
yes tomorrow's exact is that
you don't exactly he can't see you
thanks good point
so it would be okay mr mr chairman this
is representative nunez it would be okay
if we turned our video on so that you
can tell it's us and then put our
picture up
no it has to be live
that's why you're voting though right
yes
while you're voting it has to be live
mr chairman representative schamberg
here again yes
this goes back to my original question
about tomorrow
we are executing bills i hope to exec
bills uh okay will there be anyone
representation wednesday or not
well i'm not coming on a wednesday
you're not
okay and we don't have a room assigned
to us wednesday
oh okay all right thank you we have a
room assigned to us on
thursday thursday okay thank you
um you have the capability to show your
face to
oh oh man jenny
yes yes but it's going to look ugly
okay what do the rest of us do
representative major on thursday
we're on we've got some pretty large
bills
and and certainly the the horse racing
is likely to have a lot of people at it
how are we going to deal with very large
execs at the same time
especially if it has to be in the room
as well as
at home if we have the time
in the morning we should be able to work
on them
on those that you and i
well we'll see let's let's talk tonight
after i have the clocks
and we'll do the easy easy ones tomorrow
and do the difficult ones i try to do
difficult ones on thursday
i don't think we'll be doing anything in
the afternoon because of the length of
the hearings
all right i'd like to thank mr shea for
having all those
uh share screen uh materials
so quickly yes really
it really makes it better than being in
our hearing room and each one
scrapped through our papers
very grateful that you were able to do
that i agree chris does a great job also
janine does a good job too thank you
not right in front of me
if we didn't have those two we
might as well stay home but
not join okay i think we've had enough
for today
represent major just one quick thing
before you go would it be advisable to
bring dra in on tuesday the 16th when
you're meeting
yes in case there's questions that um
the committee members come up with that
they could
go back research and come back on the
18th with yes
okay so i'll let them know um and i'll
give them
the questions i have to date but if any
members have other um
questions related to any of the
outstanding taxes you're still working
on
or want to revisit any just send the
questions to me and i'll make sure dra
gets those
okay and then i'll call you this
afternoon about the hhs
for the vaccine update
if we don't hurry along we're going to
have to read the thermostat
okay anything important now if not
we will call it a day okay thank you
everybody